No,
three,
two,
one.
I always wonder what you base your
countdown on,
Jamie.
You got two things going.
Why is it an accurate count on or use
roughly guessing like a five count
because we have a.
does it delay the thing and then the
thing and that thing and.
Okay,
well we're live.
Chris,
what's up to to be here.
Thanks for doing this man.
My pleasure.
We were just talking about the term
Paleo,
like I put up a that we're gonna talk
about nutrition and diet and all that
good stuff and then somebody went to
your page and it says,
you know,
Paleo and lifestyle expert.
As soon as you have that word Paleo,
people go,
oh,
fuck.
Serious baggage.
That's true.
I mean,
every day I think about,
Oh,
I kinda wish I never would have used
this word.
Yeah.
Well let's Mark Sisson went with primal.
He's.
He uses that primal blueprint.
Yeah.
You know,
that's his sort of distinction of it.
I like that.
I mean they're both just words is what
it really comes down to A.
I thought about,
I wrote a book that has the word Paleo
in it,
and I thought about even before I
published a book,
I was thinking,
you know,
what I'm talking about is not really
what people mean when they say Paleo.
It's a lot more inclusive and a lot less
dogmatic and if I use this word,
there's going to be pros and cons.
The pro is people recognize it.
It's,
it's one word that that points at a
whole way of thinking.
I could have called it the new nutrient
dense ancestral,
you know,
nutrition book,
but that's not too catchy and like five
people that read it.
Um,
and,
but on the other hand,
Paleo has a ton of baggage,
as you said.
You know,
it,
it.
People get a certain idea when they hear
that word.
And for some it's good.
For others it's kind of neutral.
They don't know anything about it.
And then for still others it's like
instant turn off and you know,
why should we be emulating our Paleo
ancestors lifestyles.
They all died when they were 30.
This is stupid,
you know,
why should we do this?
So it's a totally loaded term,
I think we just need to get past it as,
as a,
you know,
an idea or a term and look at what it's
really pointing at it and evaluated on
that basis.
Yeah,
I think that makes a lot sense.
And also there was the issue with the
term Paleolithic,
like using the term Paleo and then there
were some articles written about the
actual diet of the Paleolithic people
where they ate everything they got a
hold of and if they got grains they eat
a ton of grains.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So,
I mean we know they weren't eating
cheese doodles and drinking big Gulps,
right?
So it's kind of easier to talk about
Paleo in terms of what it didn't
include.
So it didn't include processed and
refined,
you know,
Brad flower cookies,
muffins,
uh,
all kinds of packaged foods that
comprise a large percentage of the
American diet.
I think that top six foods now,
our grain based desserts,
sugar sweetened beverages,
pizza.
I'm chicken dishes,
which are primarily fried chicken
nuggets.
I'm forgetting the other two,
but it's all crap.
You know,
the foods wasn't the prime or six
primary foods.
America Americans is just completely
nutrient depleted junk,
you know,
so we can all agree that our Paleolithic
ancestors weren't eating those foods and
then we know it's pretty clear that they
were eating a lot of neat.
Well,
I'm sure we'll talk about that.
Meat and fish,
wild fruits and vegetables,
not the domesticated varieties that
we're eating today,
but wild fruits and vegetables,
nuts and seeds and some starchy plants.
So,
so,
so those are the two extremes.
If we bracketed and then things like
grains and the GMS were more of a
question mark,
like there's some recent evidence that
shows that that lagoon consumption was
probably pretty more common than we
thought amongst our Paleo ancestors.
They were,
they came later onto the scene,
but if they were there,
they probably ate them.
Is that based on geography?
Like we're lagoons are present.
Exactly.
And what other food sources were
available.
It's pretty clear that they weren't the
first option.
You know,
if they were able to slaughter an
animal,
they would have done that and,
and eating the organs and the brain.
And probably throw in the muscle meat to
the dogs.
Really?
Yeah.
We have it backwards.
I mean,
when you look at traditional hunter
gatherers and the way they eat animals,
they go just like wild animals do.
When wild animal kills another animal,
it goes straight for the organs.
And that's because the organs are way
more nutrient dense than the muscle
needs.
Um,
and so traditional peoples,
they knew the same thing even without
having access to science and you know,
knowing even what a nutrient was,
they just over generations figured out
that eating liver and the kidneys and
the spleen and the brain was,
was going to give them more energy,
make them feel better,
make them more fertile than eating the
muscle meats.
But did they eat the muscle meats at
all?
I mean,
it seems to me that they probably did
because they hungry.
They use every part of the animal,
but it was clear that the organs were
where the,
the,
the favorite thing to eat.
And how do we know this?
I'm just start anthropological studies
of hunter gathers a contemporary hunter
gatherers,
you know,
in the sixties,
seventies,
eighties,
there aren't many extent hunter gatherer
groups that we can even study now
because they've,
you know,
they've all been basically assimilated.
Um,
but you know,
like the Hudson Hunter gatherers in
Africa and there are some groups that
are still living a lifestyle that's
relatively close to what they were
living for the last 10,000
years.
And we can learn a lot by studying those
groups.
And that's a pretty common theme in all
of these traditional peoples as they.
They focused on eating the organ meats,
you know,
second would be probably meet another
animal products in terms of nutrient
density.
They ate a much broader variety of plant
species and we eat like,
you know,
across the world.
Most people eat,
you know,
four to eight plant species in their
diet.
A traditional hunter gatherer groups.
It was over 100.
Wow.
They were just whatever was edible,
huge diversity of plants.
And that of course increase the nutrient
density,
increase the fiber that they were
eating,
which we now know feeds of beneficial
gut bacteria.
Which has all kinds of uh,
benefits for health and,
and again,
they weren't eating the foods that we
are now,
you know,
uh,
eating way more than we're eating
anything else.
And when I say we,
I mean just Americans or people living
in the industrialized world in general
and that's,
that's a problem because of this concept
of a species appropriate diet and we
know that all organisms evolve,
evolve in a certain environment and
they're are adapted to survive in that
environment and when their diet or
lifestyle it gets too far from what they
evolved for,
this mismatch occurs.
And that mismatch is really responsible
for all modern disease.
Yeah.
That is something that I thought was
really interesting,
but reading some of your work and some
of your articles that you had sort of
narrowed down to I believe eight.
The eight different factors that
contribute to a,
to ill health that are a lot of times
ignored when diseases are,
when,
when someone gets,
when someone gets diagnosed with an
illness,
almost immediately there's a drug
prescribed to treat the illness,
but there's not like sort of,
um,
backing up of the process to find out.
Okay,
how did you get to this position?
Like what is your diet like?
Are you getting enough sleep?
What kind of stress are you under?
Is your body.
I'm exposed to toxins on a regular basis
like you do you work with paint,
you know what I mean?
Are you,
are you near something that's really bad
for you to breathe?
Yeah.
I mean,
the analogy I like to use is you have a
rock in your shoe and it's making your
foot hurt.
You could take advil,
right?
And it's gonna.
You'll probably feel less pain,
but you could also just take your shoe
off and dump out that rock.
That would be a better idea.
Right?
I think we can all agree on that.
And our Ma,
our medical system is the equivalent of
taking advil when you have that rock in
your shoe,
if you have high blood pressure,
you go to the doctor,
you'll get a medication to lower it.
If you have high cholesterol,
you'll be prescribed to staten and those
can be effective at bringing those
numbers down.
But there's rarely any investigation
into what's causing that symptom in the
first place.
And you know,
the problem with that is take the high
blood pressure medication,
it lowers your blood pressure,
but then you have no libido.
And so what's the solution there?
Another drug that increases your libido,
you get via Viagara,
but then Viagra,
you know,
causes of some other side effect.
And then you get prescribed another drug
to deal with that side effect.
And then by the time you're 65 or 70,
you're taking seven or eight
medications.
And the statistics actually bear this
out.
You know,
most people at that age are taking two
handfuls of pills just to,
you know,
to,
uh,
to be able to get by.
And that's really not the way that human
beings evolved,
evolved and are designed for.
It's also it becomes a problem because
there's a lot of money being made on
selling those things.
Absolutely.
And the pharmaceutical industry is this
gigantic monster of a business where
they're just making billions and
billions of dollars and there's so much
momentum when you have a big industry
that absolutely.
And they realized a while back that the
big money in drugs is not in treating
sick people.
It's in treating healthy people because
they are way more healthy people than
there are sick people.
And so once you get done with making
drugs to treat diseases,
you need to start making drugs to give
to people who are fundamentally healthy
but maybe have like some one lab marker
that's out of range.
So take stat and drugs for example.
You know,
there's only a certain number of people
that have already had heart attacks and
are in danger,
you know,
high risk of having another heart
attack.
So you first stat and drug sales to
grow.
They need to expand beyond that
population and start prescribing them to
people who aren't necessarily at high
risk for heart disease,
but um,
you know,
maybe have slightly high cholesterol and
that's where the real money is made.
Wow.
So,
so people that don't have really health
consequences of this,
like,
uh,
like if you have high cholesterol,
high cholesterol is a lot of times
associated with diet.
Yeah.
But the reality of cholesterol and
cholesterol rich diets and blood lipids
is that it doesn't really move the
needle.
It's so much more complex than that.
And what is the cause of like if a
person has high cholesterol,
what are the potential causes?
So diet is definitely one genetics or
not,
or just certain genetic polymorphisms
that make you more susceptible to having
high cholesterol.
But there are a number of causes.
They're lesser known.
So poor thyroid function.
It's one cause because thyroid hormones
required to clear ldl cholesterol from
the circulation.
So if you have,
you know,
even suboptimal thyroid function,
not frank,
hi.
You know,
full on hypothyroidism,
but just a little bit of have a problem
with thyroid.
Your cholesterol can be high,
and in fact,
back in the eighties or seventies before
statens were a,
became a bigger part of the,
of the treatment of high cholesterol
doctors east to use low dose of thyroid
hormone to treat high cholesterol.
So they knew this at one time,
um,
disrupted gut microbiome and leaky gut,
which I know you've talked about on this
show with other guests,
a ldl is actually an antimicrobial
substance.
So the liver will make more ldl
particles if there's toxins,
endotoxins getting into the bloodstream
from the gut.
Um,
infections can raise cholesterol,
ldl and toxins can do that too.
So there's studies showing mercury
toxicity,
for example,
can raise cholesterol.
So these are all the potential
underlying causes of high cholesterol.
So if someone comes to see me and they
have that problem,
I'm going to test for all of those
things.
I'm going to address those first.
And then we see what happens and if
their liquids normalized after that,
great.
You know,
we've done our work and we end the avoid
taking a drug that they never needed to
take in the first place.
If we retest and they're still in,
their levels are still high,
then we have a bigger conversation about
what the actual risk is given their
level,
their age,
their sex,
their family history,
the absence or presence of other risk
factors like high blood pressure and uh,
inflammation,
you know,
so it's,
it's,
it's really complex.
And then this idea that there's just an
arbitrary number for total cholesterol
and if you're higher than that,
you need to take a staton and if you're
lower than that,
you don't is,
um,
I don't,
I can't think of a good comparison right
now,
but it's ridiculously over simplified
and it also has some effect,
um,
or your,
your,
your eight year amount of exercise and
your overall,
uh,
amount of,
what you put your body through as far as
like stress,
exercise,
activity that has some sort of an effect
on it as well.
Absolutely.
Cholesterol is a repair substance too.
So if there's any kind of damage,
endothelial damage in the arteries and
the lining of the arteries,
cholesterol can be moved to that site to
repair the damage.
Um,
lifestyle choices definitely play a
role.
So you know,
we need,
I think getting back to your,
to the original point here,
we need to be thinking more holistically
about what causes disease and how to
treat it instead of just using bandaid
approaches that suppress symptoms.
I mean we don't really have healthcare.
We have disease management not to toe.
That's a fundamental difference that we
need to understand.
Like if you think of disease as a
spectrum where you know the far end is
death and here is perfect health.
Very rarely do people go from perfect
health to,
you know,
straight to death.
I mean that happens in trauma accidents
and things like that.
But usually we progressed along that
spectrum and our conventional medical
system is designed to intervene at the
far end of that spectrum.
You know,
when we're,
we're already kind of past the point of
no return.
You know,
we had these drugs that suppress
symptoms.
We have pretty amazing trauma care.
Like if I get hit by a bus,
I don't want to go to the hospital,
you know,
we're,
we're starting to be able to restore
sight to the blind and do these
incredible things.
But they're all at that far end of the
spectrum.
A conventional medicine is really lousy
at preventing disease in the first place
or treating it at,
at this end of the spectrum when it's
closer to health and it's really bad at
promoting health.
In fact,
in most medical school textbooks,
there's not even a definition of health.
It's just basically the absence of
disease.
But I think we can do better than that.
Yeah.
It just seems logical.
I mean,
it seems that,
that,
that should be an approach that everyone
should consider when you're looking at
the broad spectrum of illnesses and
diseases and injuries and all those
different factors that are involved in
making someone ill that this is what
you're saying seems so common sense,
but it's not common at all.
Not Common at all.
Um,
it does seem common sense to me and I
think part of the problem.
I mean,
you hinted at it before with big Pharma,
it's like there's little incentive for
big Pharma,
big Pharma to promote this kind of
approach.
Why,
why,
you know,
what's their interest in doing that?
I mean,
it means less sales for them.
They're there for profit corporations
that are publicly owned and it's in
their best interests of the shareholders
to do things that grow the company and
grow the business.
Right?
That's just how it is.
That's how,
that's how our system is.
And you know,
that's,
that's a whole nother discussion.
But um,
it,
it's problematic when it comes to
healthcare because you know,
the way it really should work is if you
go into your doctor and you have high
cholesterol,
high blood pressure,
your doctor sits down,
says,
asked you a whole bunch of questions
about what you're eating,
how you living,
are you sleeping,
are you exercising,
you taking care of yourself,
you managing your stress?
And then they do a whole bunch of
testing.
They don't just test your blood
pressure,
they don't just test your cholesterol,
they test your gut,
they test your,
your hpa axis,
which is what governs your whole stress
response.
They list HPA,
hypothalamic pituitary adrenal axis.
So it's this,
the brain,
basically the connection between the
brains and the brain and the adrenal
glands,
and it governs our stress response.
So there are ways that we can test it to
see how you're being affected by stress.
So if you're under a lot of stress
that's causing hormonal changes in your
body,
it can affect every aspect of your how
we can test for this.
So they would do a lot of testing
upfront,
which would be more expensive initially,
but down the line it would save
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
dollars per patient.
So let's take someone with type full
fledge type two diabetes,
depending on the estimate that I've
seen,
it can cost anywhere from 60 to 80,000
to $400,000
to care for that patient over the,
their lifetime to the insurance company.
Because insurance is paying for a lot of
these procedures.
They develop,
let's say retinopathy later.
They go blind.
They,
you know,
they,
they require multiple operations and
surgeries.
They're taking expensive drugs.
All of this stuff adds up.
But let's say we could have spent $1,500
right off the bat when before they even
develop type two diabetes to identify
what was happening and you know,
catch it before it happened and
intervene.
Then yeah,
you spend a little bit more upfront,
but you ended up saving tens if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars over
the lifetime of the patient,
so I think eventually the insurance
companies are going to realize this
because there are also for profit
businesses and they're interested
ultimately in things that can save
money.
They just don't yet see functional
medicine,
which is what we're talking about right
here as something that could potentially
save them a lot of money.
They see it as something that they have
to spend money on because the testing is
more expensive upfront,
but they're not looking at the longterm
game.
I wonder if pharmaceutical companies are
just going to buy up the insurance
companies and use it like as a write
off.
A cynical person may have that thought.
I mean I would,
if I was a pharmaceutical company,
I saw the writing on the wall like,
hey,
people are having way more access to
information about health than ever
before.
They're going to start to make these
healthy choices and we're kind of fuck
guys,
listen.
What we're going to do is we've got to
get in there early.
Stranger things have happened.
There's a lot of problems with this in
terms of like doctors,
when you,
uh,
you're a doctor,
you have a line of patients waiting to
get into your office and you have
standard model of treatment that you've
been sort of practicing for a long time.
So to deviate from this path and to say,
hey,
you know,
this whole rock in the shoe analogy that
you brought up,
which is brilliant,
it's a perfect way to describe it.
This all makes sense and it's logical
and everything like that.
But,
uh,
you know,
hey,
insurance is not going to cover all
these different tests.
We have a giant issue also in getting
people to be proactive to actually do
something.
How many people do we know?
I know a bunch that are fat,
that talk about being fat,
that have poor diets that drink too much
and eat too much sugar and constantly
eating crap and not exercising.
They're 100 percent intellectually aware
of this and they don't do a goddamn
thing about it.
Yeah,
you're right.
It's a systemic problem,
so if we break it down,
you know,
on the,
on the doctor care providers side and
the inpatient side,
so the care provider's side,
I mean they're as much victims as,
as we are.
It's as,
as patients are to um,
to this whole system that's been set up
because as you pointed out,
like the way the system works,
most doctors who were working in an Hmo
type of setting have like seven to 10
minutes to spend with a patient that's
so crazy.
That's not enough time to have the kind
of conversation that you need to have
even even to get beyond saying hello and
writing a prescription,
a prescription,
which is basically what happens in of
those encounters.
And then you also mentioned that the
standard of care,
so they're legally required to,
to,
to take certain actions and certain
circumstances and they,
their medical license and their whole
career could be at risk if they don't do
that.
So even if they question,
for example,
prescribing statens to a patient who has
a total cholesterol of 2:40
but no other risk factors.
If they don't do that,
then they could actually lose their job.
And so,
so it's,
it's not,
I'm not being critical of individual
doctors here.
I'm criticizing the whole system that
we've created that,
that I know many doctors,
I trained doctors and I know many
doctors and I can say that most of them
are aware that the way that we're doing
things is not working and they want to
change it as much as anybody else,
but they feel constrained by the system.
And then the other problem is,
you know,
us as individuals,
like the level of responsibility for our
own health that we take.
And I think,
you know,
this,
we were,
we all ultimately are responsible.
So,
so let,
let me just say that,
but it's also true that we're influenced
by the system that we are part of.
And so,
uh,
you know,
you,
you get this whole culture which is
basically oriented around disease
management and suppressing symptoms with
drugs.
And that's what patients come to expect.
And so I've heard from many doctors and
there've actually been studies on this
so that patients will go in to the
doctor and they'll,
they'll request a drug and they won't be
satisfied unless they leave with a
prescription for that drug,
whether it's indicated for them or not.
And this is because we're one of only
two countries in the world that has
direct to consumer drug advertising,
the US and New Zealand and only two
countries in the whole world that allow
ads in magazines that are targeted
towards consumers for drugs and the risk
in doing this is exactly what we're
talking about now.
You get someone who's seen a drug ad in
a magazine.
They're like,
I need that drug.
They go into the doctor,
they ask for it.
The doctor knows it's not right for
them,
but the patient's not going to be
satisfied unless they get that
prescription.
So the doctor caves and gives them that
I did not know we were one of two
countries in the whole world.
I thought new New Zealand was a little
more on the ball.
It's surprising in a way that New
Zealand,
you're a stupid as we are,
but yeah,
that's.
That's a giant problem.
The did that advertising model.
Well,
advertising is a giant problem period
for people because we're so susceptible
to influence
and they've shown this with food in
particular that you know this the
advert,
the big,
there's big Pharma and there's big food
and big food.
Capital B,
capital F is this whole industrial food
production system that is invested in
selling us crap and they are well aware
of how,
you know,
they study how to do this,
so they have food scientists on staff
that study the palatability and reward
value of food.
This is like technical stuff like how
foods stimulates the,
the reward centers in our brain and
that,
that pringles add hope,
bet you can't just eat one.
They will win that bet because they
have,
you know,
scientists on staff that have engineered
that food to make sure that you do eat
more than just one because they,
they,
they study things like mouth feel and
all of the different things that go into
stimulating the reward centers in our
brain to make us eat more than we
should.
And so we are being manipulated and you
know,
we have a responsibility to see that and
to get beyond it.
I'm not saying it's not a cop out,
you know,
people aren't responsible for their
actions,
but it's,
you know,
there's more to it.
We're,
we're,
we're in this environment where we're
being consistently manipulated every
day.
It is very sneaky.
The pringles things in particular.
Absolutely.
I mean,
there,
Ryan pulled that out there.
I think about like if you had a plate
and there's a,
you have a baked potato with no salt or
butter on one plate and then you've got
another plate and it's potato.
It's pringles.
What do you think you're going to eat
more of?
I mean it's just,
these are hardwired evolutionary
mechanisms.
We,
we're,
we're hardwired to seek out novelty
variety because it would ensure in an,
in a preindustrial food environment that
kind of hard wiring would actually be a
selective advantage,
meaning it would help us survive in a
Paleolithic type of environment because
we would seek out foods that had a
variety of flavors,
usually different flavors means
different kinds of nutrients.
So we would,
uh,
someone who had that kind of programming
would be more likely to survive.
But when you take that evolutionary
programming that was designed when we
are living in a,
you know,
in a payload Olympic type of
environment,
and you transfer that into this modern
environment that we live in where you've
got the 7:11
on every corner with Doritos and big
Gulps and candy and all this stuff.
It's a total unmitigated disaster.
Well,
that environment,
that environment of like a seven slash
11 when you go in there and there's just
zero healthy choices and all of it is
sugar drinks and these fucked up snacks
that have no nutrients.
And I'm like,
yeah,
that it's,
it's such a bizarre common place that
you can just pull into any one of those
things.
There's so many of them and they're just
overwhelmed with unhealthy choices all
over the world to now and you know,
we've exported our crap to all of these
other countries in the world and,
and pretty much any country.
I mean,
I,
in my twenties,
I traveled all over the world surfing
and I was shocked at,
you know,
I'd,
I'd be in this really remote place in
Indonesia and I'd see like a coca cola
barge going,
going by from island to island in this
little archipelago where there was
nothing,
you know,
just huts on every assignment,
but then you come up to this little hut
and there'd be like a thing of coca cola
bottles,
you know,
crazy.
And we've managed to export this
everywhere and it's just,
you know,
people,
uh,
it's hard to go against evolutionary
programming because this,
it's real and it's until unconscious.
It's,
it's below the,
the cognitive center of our brain where
we can rationally think about it.
I mean,
you mentioned before people who are
overweight but don't make healthy
choices,
that's not because they don't
intellectually understand that they need
to make healthy choices.
It's that they're fighting against this
deeply hardwired programming that is
totally incompatible with the modern
food environment that we have and you
know,
for whatever reason,
some people are more successful at
getting past that than others.
Yeah.
About being able to attach
intellectually detached from the
instincts where you,
you know,
for a fact that all these things are
definitely bad for you.
Even though there's a compelling desire
to take them in,
they have this ability to step back.
Yeah.
It's,
that's,
that's sort of a learn thing.
It's a learn thing,
you know?
It's not a natural thing.
I mean,
if you it,
what's more natural is to see something
that you crave and to eat and to eat it
or drink it.
I mean not that is a natural animal
human experience.
What's less natural is to see that,
feel it,
and then have a thought that says,
no,
this is actually not going to be good
for me.
And so I'm going to make a different
choice.
I mean,
not.
That's a,
that's a.
and I don't think it's the same.
I don't think we even experienced those
cravings in the same way.
Like there are.
Um,
I mean,
for example,
if someone has a really screwed up gut
and they've got a lot of bad bacteria or
they have some fun,
they have fungal overgrowth or something
going on in there,
those bacteria we now know and yeast can
produce chemicals that actually affect
our brain chemistry so that someone
who's got a disrupted gut microbiome
might experience those cravings way more
strongly than I do.
And so it's harder for them to intervene
and stop that because it's almost like
they have a,
an alien presence in,
in their body that is creating these
foods.
And it's really hard to overcome that.
I'm glad you brought that up because
that was one of the things I was going
to bring up next.
Um,
the idea that your gut biome actually
controls your cravings and controls
your,
your desires for things and also when
you cure that up or when you heal it and
you start taking in healthy probiotics,
your desires for different foods sort of
emerge for me over the last few years,
like say three years plus I've really
gotten into probiotics,
got really heavily into drinking
Kombucha on a daily basis.
And then I started eating a lot of Chee
and a lot of fermented cabbage and then
it became Kiefer and a lot of other
different things.
And now I take on it total gut health
package with every food that I eat every
time I eat something.
And I think that like really
concentrating on probiotics has boosted
my immune system.
I'm very rarely sick if I'm sick,
even though I travel so much.
If I'm sick,
it's for very short amount of time.
Right.
And then I snapped back pretty quickly
and my desire for sugary foods is almost
nonexistent unless I'm drunk or I just
want to indulge.
But like I used to have this massive
desire all the time to eat like a
sandwich or eat a bowl of pasta or,
and now I look at it and if it's not
even really food like it,
my mind has sort of reached a tipping
point.
And then also my,
my gut biome,
I believe.
I mean I'm just guessing has changed
where like if someone is a piece of cake
laying around,
I don't look at that piece of cake and
go,
God,
I got to stuff that in my face.
I look at it and go,
that is a lot of problems.
That's a lot of sugar.
That's a lot of not good for you.
I'm going to,
it's going to give me some mouth
pleasure and then I'm going to feel
fucking terrible our
right.
Yeah.
No,
I think that's all true.
All supported by the research.
There's a lot of research now on the gut
brain access which recognizes the bi
directional connection between the gut
and the brain.
So in other words,
how the health of our gut and our gut
microbiome directly influences brain
chemistry.
Likewise,
our brain chemistry,
I directly influences our gut so it can
work in both directions.
So if you're under severe stress,
for example,
I think most people recognize the
phrases,
butterflies in my stomach before you go
onstage and perform,
that you feel that,
you know,
I don't know if you experienced that now
since he performed so much.
Do you still,
do you still get the.
Something's really important.
Like I'm going to do a
yeah,
comedy special that I'm gonna fail or
something like that and I get like a
little nervous most of the time you
just,
it's a heightened sense of like,
okay,
here we go right now.
But when you were about to do something
that's scary,
your pants right.
There's another less for fine example of
the gut brain connection.
So it's been in our lexicon for a long
time.
So I think like on a popular basis,
most people are like,
Duh.
Yeah,
I know my brain's connected,
my gut.
But it's only been in the last 20,
30 years that the research has really
come around to,
you know,
clarifying what those relationships are.
So,
um,
we know that changes in the gut
microbiome can affect our brain
chemistry and in fact,
the,
uh,
the prevailing theory now of what
actually causes depression is called the
inflammatory cytokine model of
depression.
And so it's not the thing that,
where your serotonin levels are
different than you know,
and,
and that's why you're depressed.
It's that you have inflammation
primarily in the gut and inflammatory
cytokines travel from your gut through
the bloodstream,
up into your brain,
across the blood brain barrier.
And they suppress the activity in the
frontal cortex which basically causes
the symptoms of depression.
So there's,
there's,
this is totally mainstream,
not fringe science,
where they recognize that depression may
be caused and anxiety may be caused by
inflammation in the gut.
So this is where the direction of
science has been heading up.
And then,
you know,
it stands to reason that if you take
probiotics,
you eat fermented foods,
you eat fermentable fibers that grow,
help feed the beneficial bacteria that
are already in your gut.
You can influence that bank brain
chemistry.
And so not only change your mood,
you know,
potentially heal depression and anxiety.
And then even,
you know,
cognitive behavioral disorders,
Adhd and things like that,
but you could also profoundly changed
the creating of food that you have
because if pathogenic bacteria feed on
sugar,
so you may not just be dealing with your
own cravings when you're craving sugar,
you're dealing with the cravings of
those pathogenic bacteria.
We know there are examples in nature of
bacteria and microorganisms changing the
behavior of their host in order to
propagate their own survival.
So,
uh,
I'm,
I'm probably gonna Butcher,
I don't remember the exact species,
but,
um,
it's a parasite that gets into a
particular insect and aquatic wildlife.
There's that.
And there's one,
a land one that causes it to crawl up to
the top of a blade of grass where it can
then be eaten by the ultimate host that,
that parasite wants to get into.
Yeah.
And I'm not remembering the exact
species,
but there's a biologist know that
microorganisms can,
can change our,
our behavior.
And,
and we like to think that we're not
animals,
but we're subject to these same
influences.
Oh,
100 percent.
I mean,
it is a very bizarre distinction that we
want to think we're people,
we're not animals,
we're special.
We,
if we've evolved beyond being animal
switch,
it's cute.
It's nice to think,
and it's nice to separate ourselves
because we're conscious and we're aware
of our actions and,
and that,
those are all absolutely correct,
but we're just a heightened state of
animal life.
Absolutely.
End of the day.
We're subject to the same influences,
right?
I think so,
and I think it causes a lot of harm to
see ourselves as separate.
I think you're right.
The term leaky gut,
what does that mean?
When people hear leaky gut,
they've heard it a bunch of times.
Um,
it's,
it's something that gets talked about a
lot when people deal with in quote
unquote gut health and probiotics,
like what does,
what is leaky gut mean?
So this is a,
this is an interesting example of how,
of what happens in research over time.
So you know,
20 or 30 years ago if you went,
if you were like a medical conference
and you use the term leaky gut,
you would have been laughed out of the
room,
you know,
it was really the province of
alternative medicine providers and
quacks.
And yet today,
if you go search on pub med,
you know,
the major clearinghouse of,
of medical studies,
you can find thousands and thousands of
articles on leaky gut.
It will be actually talked about with
the term intestinal permeability.
And so what,
what this means is a,
it,
if you,
it's kind of interesting think about
this,
but your intestine is bake is basically
a,
uh,
it's a,
it's a hollow tube that goes from your
mouth to your anus and anything inside
the intestine is technically outside of
the body.
Really.
It's weird to think of that way,
but if you have a tube that's going all
the way through your body and anything
that's inside that tube is not actually
inside your body.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So the,
the tubes job is to decide what gets
inside of the body and what stays out
because anything that doesn't get
absorbed just gets eliminated as waste
without ever getting into your body.
And we couldn't survive if we didn't
have this ability to discern friend from
foe.
It's supposed to let nutrients that we
need in,
but keep toxins and other wastes out.
Right?
So that's the,
the,
one of the fundamental purposes of the
gut barriers to it,
it's other guide is to be a barrier.
Basically diarrhea when you're not well,
exactly.
Clear that stuff out.
Let's go everybody,
everybody,
everybody out right away.
So,
um,
the,
the guide is primarily a barrier.
It's a barrier system and when,
when that's working well it opens and
closes appropriately.
And so,
you know,
oh,
nutrient,
okay,
open,
let that in talks and waste closed.
Don't let that in.
Uh,
and,
and so everyone's gut is permeable in an
appropriate way,
right?
When it's working well,
because if it wasn't permeable,
it wouldn't be,
we would die,
we wouldn't be able to absorb nutrients.
Um,
but the other side of that spectrum is
if it stops being permeable at the right
times and starts letting things in that
shouldn't be in there in the first
place.
That's what's called leaky gut.
You know,
you basically have an inability to to
keep out stuff that's not supposed to
get into your body.
And then like so some of some examples
would be large protein molecules.
Typically we digest protein into small
peptides that our immune system doesn't
recognize it as foreign invaders and is
able to use to grow muscle and do all
the things that protein helps us to do.
But if large protein molecules that have
not been properly digested,
sneak into the bloodstream,
our body rec sees those things as
foreign presence and creates antibodies
to attack them.
And that's why we develop food allergies
or food intolerances.
Another thing that gets through the gut
that shouldn't is called endotoxins.
So these are toxins produced by a
certain species of bacteria.
Things like lipopolysaccharide and they
can get through the gut barrier and then
our body produces antibodies to them and
attacks them as if they're foreign
invaders,
which they are in that case,
they shouldn't be in there in the first
place.
And all of this basically creates a
systemic inflammatory response.
So,
um,
you know,
whether it's food antigens that are
getting in there that shouldn't be,
or whether it's back bacterial
endotoxins that are getting in there,
that shouldn't be leaky gut leads to
this chronic low grade infection,
inflammation and basically all modern
diseases that kill us like diabetes,
heart disease,
uh,
even some of the ones we've already
talked about,
depression doesn't necessarily kill us,
but all of the mental and behavioral
diseases,
autoimmune disease,
which now in fact one in four women and
one in six men,
just crazy.
And given that they don't really exist
in traditional hunter gatherer
societies,
all of these are inflammatory
conditions.
So,
uh,
something that contributes to
inflammation is going to significantly
increase our risk of acquiring one of
these diseases.
And then eventually dying from one of
them.
Now when we say inflammation,
that's another term that people here
really,
but I don't think they necessarily
understand.
It's along the lines of
it.
So like you did an awesome job clearing
the thing for me too.
It's solidified,
but inflammation.
Why is inflammation caused by sugars?
Why's it caused by simple sugars and
corn syrup and things on those lines.
Too much simple carbohydrates,
like what is,
what is causing that?
So there's this great paper published a
few years ago by a professor from New
Zealand,
actually Ian Spread,
Barry,
I think is his name.
Um,
forgive me if I'm not getting that right
in,
but he,
a distinguished between two different
types of carbohydrates,
a cellular and cellular,
a cellular meaning lacking cell membrane
and a cellular carbs are carbs that have
been heavily processed where their
natural cells that would be found in a
plant,
in a whole plant,
like a start,
like a sweet potato or a potato or
something like that have been broken
down in the processing.
So you have white flour for example.
Um,
you know,
originally came from a whole wheat plant
that had its cells intact,
but then it's been the seed or the
kernel of the whole wheat has been
removed and you just have the starch
with no cell cells anymore.
And what that means is,
um,
with,
with cellular carbohydrates,
our body has to really work to break
those down and the actual glucose,
the carbohydrate itself is relatively
inaccessible because we have to work so
hard to digest it and get at it.
If you think of an analogy like a nut,
you know,
like a whole walnut,
it,
you know,
you have to do a lot to get to that.
So it's gonna be hard to overeat those,
um,
in a,
in a kind of a traditional setting
because there's so much work involved at
getting at it.
Whereas if you have a bag of walnuts
from trader Joe's that have already been
shelled and,
and,
and they're just sitting there salted,
you can just pound a whole bunch of
those.
So with this,
a cellular carbohydrate,
it's basically the equivalent of
removing the shells from the nuts and
just making those carbohydrates super
accessible.
Not only to us but to the bacteria in
our gut,
and so his argument was that when we eat
a lot of processed and refined sugars
that are,
that are highly accessible to to to us
and also to our gut bacteria,
we basically create an imbalance in the
gut where you have a proliferation of
bad pathogenic bacteria that thrive on
sugar and a reduction of good bacteria
that we need to be healthy and not
imbalanced.
Then creates an inflammatory gut
microbiota and as I described before
that those inflammatory cytokines that
are produced in the gut,
they can travel out from the gut and
affect the whole body systemically.
So you know,
25 years,
100 years ago,
hippocrates said,
all disease begins in the gut and he
didn't know,
you know,
any.
He didn't have any of this modern
science that we have now that shows that
this is true,
but he,
it turns out that he,
he was right.
That's fascinating that people have
these ancients sayings like,
follow your heart.
And then we found out like fairly
recently,
within the last few decades at the heart
is filled with neurons.
Right?
And that there might actually be some
sort of memory or thinking,
you know,
quote unquote going on in your heart
and then having a sense of purpose is
associated with greater longevity and
better health,
which is also following your heart.
Very strange sort of sentiments that
turned out to be like,
you think of them as just sort of old
tales or old things that people say old
expressions,
but they turn out to actually have some
basis in fact,
almost instinctually
I think we're,
we're kind of recovering lost knowledge
at this point in a lot of ways and,
but we're recovering it in different
way.
Like we're,
we're using modern scientific tools to
validate or clarify ancient wisdom
that's been around for a long time and I
think they both have a place.
And,
and I personally think it's fascinating
to learn what the mechanisms are that
explained that,
that wisdom in those sayings.
But I think we can sometimes be too
quick to dismiss that wisdom as being
like,
you know,
silly or stupid or not nonscientific.
Yeah.
I,
I definitely think.
Well,
I think it's very important that we
today in this day have the tools to use
science to sort of explain unequivocably
why these things are factors in why
these things exist and that we've proven
in these studies.
These are peer reviewed.
Here we go.
Here's the studies.
It showed that.
Oh yeah,
well there's neurons in the heart.
Oh yeah.
Well that makes sense.
You think that way?
Oh,
there's biome.
There's a,
there's actually like organisms and I
think the way you described as great
that there's like an alien living inside
you that wants sugar because it really
kind of is that there's organisms in our
body.
I got,
I,
I heard it explained once.
I never forgot it,
that there's more eco lie living inside
your gut than there have ever been
people ever.
Right?
Yeah.
And there are more microorganisms in our
gut than there are stars in the
universe.
I think some crazy stuff.
So that's where I step in and say,
how's that possible?
It doesn't make any sense.
The Universe is infinite.
Right?
Well,
there is that.
I mean,
I think that was the,
the early conception.
They're not,
they maybe haven't read about the
multiverse theories.
Yeah.
Because someone
who's like enormous,
like Ralphie May,
he has more cells,
right?
So he is,
he's a,
he's a bigger universe.
Like how does that work?
Well,
what you said about science is really
true and I mean I love science.
I'm dead.
I'm going,
I spend most of my days in interacting
with science in some way and I think
it's worth pointing out that there is
some real um,
problems with the way science is
conducted today and uh,
I think we run the risk of,
you know,
of worshiping like the randomized
clinical trial and at the expense of
other kinds of knowledge that can be
just as important or more important in,
in certain ways.
Well,
one of the things that you brought up
that I think is very important is who is
funding some of these trials on
pharmaceutical drugs and the efficacy of
them and how they profit off of it and
how,
how many studies are sort of thrown out
that don't fit the narrative.
The file drawer phenomenon.
Yeah.
Explain that.
Well,
so two thirds of medical research is
funded by big Pharma and that makes,
yeah,
two thirds.
So,
um,
you know,
this is just human nature.
Upton Sinclair said it's difficult to
get a man to understand something when
his salary depends on him not
understanding it.
It's one of my favorite quotes because
it explains a lot,
right?
And,
um,
so you can look at it just in terms of
basic human nature,
like if you're a researcher,
you're being funded by a pharmaceutical
company,
you know,
even if it's not conscious,
there's a subconscious thing there where
you know that if your results are
negative and don't support that drug,
you're less likely to get the next,
your next project funded and you're a
human being.
You want to have a job,
you want,
you want your work to be funded.
I mean,
that's,
it's really easy to understand,
right?
It's not like these are bad people who
are all like in conspiracy to,
to,
um,
push drugs on us.
I think most researchers are good,
good people and trying to do the right
thing.
Um,
but it's a way that the system set up,
that's the problem where they need to
depend on pharmaceutical companies for
their funding and it's really hard,
you know,
don't bite the hand that feeds you.
It's just,
it's,
it's a time,
you know,
the age old saying,
and there's a lot to that.
Um,
up until recently,
I think there've been some recent
changes here,
but,
uh,
researchers,
we're not required.
A pharmaceutical companies were not
required to publish negative results.
So if they did a drug trial and the
results didn't support the drug,
it turned out that placebo,
it was more effective or you know,
their drug had side effects that made it
not,
not usable.
They,
those studies just basically go into
file drawer that they wouldn't actually
be published in a journal.
And there's been a movement to change
that to where,
you know,
if a study is conducted,
it needs to be registered and then no
matter what the results are,
they need to be published so that people
have a chance to see not just the
positive results that support the drug
trials.
But the ones that didn't.
It'd be nice if that was retroactive,
right?
Um,
but then there are other problems like
fraud and so,
uh,
there was a pretty big study published
in Jama a little while back by Java is
Journal of American Medical Association,
you know,
very prominent prestigious journal and
it was a guy named Charles siefert and
he basically looked at the FDA,
a monitoring of drug trials.
So the FDA's job,
one of their jobs is to make sure that
the trial is being done to,
uh,
determine whether a medication is
effective or done the way they should be
and that,
you know,
there's no falsification of patient data
or,
and that patients are being there,
their health is being protected
adequately and there's no fraud going
on.
So what he found was that in a,
in a shocking number of cases where
there was fraud,
where the FDA actually I did identify
fraud and it was serious enough that
they took action in 96 percent of cases,
the action that they took was not
reported in any scientific journal.
So let me give you a few examples.
Like in one case,
a researcher changed patient data to
hide the patient had preexisting kidney
and liver problems and they gave this
guy chemotherapy treatment and he died
and then the researcher ended up
spending six years in jail and that was
never mentioned in the study that was
based on that trial data lake that was
later published.
So that's one example.
Another example I did they do that.
What was the most note?
There's no,
uh,
the motivation is to get the drug
approved and why would they hide the
fact that this guy,
that the FDA doesn't require companies,
pharmaceutical companies to publish that
data and because they say in their
language and according to,
to see for it in this paper,
it's more essentially more important to
the FDA to protect the commercial
interests of these companies than it is
to protect public health.
Even though this is an agency that is
ostensibly there to protect public
health,
skype.
So maybe I'm getting it wrong.
He had preexisting liver disease,
liver and kidney issues and cancer and a
researcher thought changed,
falsified his data and covered up that
he,
that,
that this was known when he was given
this chemotherapy drug.
But why would they do that?
I just don't understand why they would
cover up the fact that it guy was
already sick.
Like,
wouldn't you think that that would be
the opposite?
Let me use another example because I
think this will help show what's
happening here.
So there was a Chinese site,
you know,
most drug trials,
they take place at different sites,
so they have multiple locations that are
testing so that they can get data on
different populations,
you know,
not just in white Americans,
also Chinese people.
And so they do it different centers.
And so there was a,
it was a trial for an anticoagulant
drug.
Um,
and,
uh,
they found that this Chinese center had
falsified a whole bunch of patient data
and change the results.
And if they took that Chinese center's
data out of the equation,
that drug would have failed.
It wouldn't have been more effective
than placebo.
But even though the FDA busted this
group in China,
the study that was published on that
drug,
it's still included that data from the
study in China and even studies that
were being published 18 months later,
still included that data in the original
data set.
So the FDA busted them,
it was clear that they had falsified the
data and yet that data is still being
included in the studies that doctors are
relying on all over the world to make
decisions about whether to prescribe
these drugs.
So there's,
there's fraud happening and whether
it's,
you know,
from financial interests or just human
error that's not actually being reported
and translating into clinical decisions
that,
that doctors are making.
So there are a lot of it.
And then the whole peer review process,
you mentioned peer review to a,
there was a pretty big study where,
um,
the,
uh,
paper was submitted to Bmj,
British Medical Journal and other big
medical journal with eight major errors
and not a single one of the 221
scientists that were asked to review the
paper,
caught all of the errors and only 30
percent recommended rejecting the paper.
And this was even more problematic
because half of those scientists were
warned in advance,
we're going to give you a paper that has
a lot of errors.
And,
and the ones who were warned didn't get
any more of the errors than the
scientists that weren't warned in
advance.
They broke them up into two groups.
Is that just lack of time to do the
research and people being overwhelmed by
a workload?
I think that's probably part of it,
but it's not really an excuse.
I don't know.
I mean it's,
it's just,
it's a problem with peer review because
our artist,
you know,
it is a big part of the scientific
method to,
to have the results validated by
somebody else.
Or two,
to review the work and make sure that
it's sound,
but what this paper indicated is that a
lot of findings that we take to be true
and valid might not actually be true and
valid.
And you may have heard about this.
It actually made the news,
um,
there was a recent,
the open science collaboration did a
review of 100 psychology studies and
that had never been replicated.
Replicating findings is really important
in the scientific method to like if you
design a study and you do it and you
have,
you find a certain result in science,
it's not really considered to be valid
unless I do it and,
and confirm your results,
you know,
or someone else does.
It's independent of you.
And in a shocking number of studies,
this never happens.
And so they,
this group went back and looked at 100
psychology studies and tried to
replicate them using the,
you know,
almost identical conditions from the
original studies.
And in they were only able to do that in
35 percent of cases there.
Uh,
another group looked at a precancer,
a clinical studies and found they could
only replicate 11 percent of those.
It's a well known saying in the
pharmaceutical world that,
that,
like more than half of the drug trials
can't be replicated and have a group of
researchers from Bayer,
from a pharmaceutical company tried to
do that in 2011.
They took a bunch of trials and try to
replicate them less than one quarter of
them.
They were able to replicate the results.
So what this means is,
um,
you know,
a study can be done,
it's never validated and then a whole
bunch of other studies are done that
refer to that study and whole fields of
scientific research are spawn on a study
that was never confirmed or validated.
So it's like a house of cards built on a
foundation of falsehood.
Well,
so,
you know,
science is great.
We need to keep improving science,
but there's a lot of problems with the
way that studies are performed right
now.
And it,
it's,
it's both,
you know,
conflicts of interest that are based on
money and it's just also human human
error.
And is it also just the overwhelming
number of studies that are being done
and how many people would have to be
there to validate all the different
money,
money basically like a,
I've talked to some research,
I was just talking to some researchers
about this and they said,
look,
nobody wants to be the second person to
discover something.
It's just not as cool.
I mean,
it's not as prestigious for your career.
So like going around replicating other
people's studies is not as exciting as
doing your own original verbally.
Yeah,
exactly.
You're a cover band and you,
it's hard to get funding for it to
replicate studies.
Whereas
if you find you have an original
finding,
especially one that's tied that
potential therapeutic use and a drug
that can be made out of that,
that's where the real money and interest
is.
So,
um,
that's one of the big problems.
And uh,
another one is just how long studies are
done for like a omega,
Omega three fats.
We've all heard about the,
these are good for us and you know,
fish oil and all of that.
When you look at studies,
most of those studies are really short
term and a back in the seventies or
eighties,
some longer term studies that are were
like eight or 10 years we're done that
found really different results for.
And what they showed is that early on
the results for one way,
but the longer the study went on,
the results started to go back in the
other direction for Omega threes.
Yeah.
We allow,
we can come back to that in a second,
but um,
the point is like,
something that happens in two weeks is
not necessarily what's going to happen
over four years,
but the problem is that the typical
studies are only lasts for two or three
weeks,
especially if they're a randomized trial
because they're enormously expensive,
you know,
to isolate all the variables and make
sure that patients are not changing too
many different things and are just doing
the intervention and to,
you know,
to do everything that needs to be done
is incredibly expensive.
And,
and so,
uh,
we have a whole bunch of research
findings that are based on two week
periods that aren't applicable to how we
live our life.
That is also,
I think,
uh,
an issue with some anecdotal reports
that people have about changing their
diet.
There's a lot of people that change
their diet and short term they feel
fantastic and they started having all
these benefits.
But then over the course of maybe three,
four or five years or so,
they started having real issues
and they don't necessarily tie that to
the Diet because they remember feeling
so much better when they first switched
to it.
So they don't think that what they're
going,
what's happening three or four years
later.
It could be the cause of their problems.
I see this all the time with vegetarian
and Vegan diets.
That's exactly what I wanted to talk to
you about.
Yeah.
In terms of that,
because most people who switched to a
vegetarian or Vegan Diet,
you're going to see some instant
benefits because of the fact that you
have much more nutrient dense foods.
You're eating a lot of vegetables.
You're,
you're,
you're changing your diet and a lot of
ways to the positive or towards a
positive,
away from what you were talking about,
those primary foods that Americans tend
to eat,
all the process sugar or the just
nonsense and chicken tenders and all
that crap that people eat,
which is just so goddamn common,
right,
so automatically over that you're going
to see some longterm benefits,
but one of the things that I've been
reading is about people that have found
that over the longterm,
the lack.
This is contrary to what a lot of people
think.
Lack of saturated fat and cholesterol,
dietary cholesterol and saturated fat
leads to hormonal imbalances,
leads to your body having a harder time
producing sex hormones and all these
different with your health or your body
almost starts robbing itself to make up
for the nutritional deficiencies of your
diet.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
we talked about this before,
but humans are animals.
We're,
we're,
we're omnivores.
And wait a minute,
I saw a video on youtube.
Here's a guy that says there's no way
that we're herbivores,
and then if we were some fucking wacky
dude was saying,
if you're really a,
an Omnivore,
you should be able to eat a squirrel.
Just grab it and eat it raw.
And like,
yeah,
no,
this was the most bizarre,
some strange arguments like we shouldn't
drink milk because,
you know,
there were the only,
uh,
you know,
we're the only animal in nature in,
in nature that drinks the milk of
another animal.
Yeah.
Well we're the only animal nature that
uses iphones to have a whole.
It's hilarious.
He said that.
What else?
Appointed people do fly planes,
movies,
call each other on the phone and tell
each other how awesome milk is.
It's a ridiculous argument.
But,
um,
so yeah,
getting back to,
to their ideological arguments more than
scientific.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So it doesn't stand up to scrutiny,
but with,
with a vegetarian or Vegan Diet.
So there's lots of different ways to
look at this.
This starting with an evolutionary
perspective,
which I was getting at,
um,
omnivores or opportunistic,
they will eat whatever is available and
they'll eat the most nutrient dense
foods that are available if they have a
choice.
And that's just,
again,
that's survival.
You know,
that an animal that is able to utilize
the nutrients that are available in its
environment to its maximum advantage is
going to survive compared to one that
doesn't.
That's basic evolutionary theory.
So,
um,
if you study traditional peoples,
as far as I know,
still there's never been a traditional
pe group that,
that has ever been identified that
voluntarily followed a Vegan or even
vegetarian diet that I know of.
So that should tell you something right
there.
And ironically,
the fact that you and I are even having
this conversation,
this wouldn't even be happening if
humans had not learned it's eaten meat.
Basically.
There are a lot of anthropologists who
now believe that eating meat was
essentially what made us human.
You know,
we came down out of the trees and we
develop the development of tools that
could crack bones to give us access to
the marrow,
which is super nutrient dense or to
sliced meat,
which allowed us to be able to digest
the meat more quickly.
Um,
number one.
And then to the development of fire,
which allowed us to cook meat and
cooking makes the nutrients in meat more
bioavailable,
allowed us to spend less time foraging
for food.
So most large primates like gorillas or
chimpanzees spend over 80 percent of
their day foraging for food because most
of the foods that we eat are really not
nutrient dense.
So they have to eat a boatload of stuff
and just sit there,
chew on the plants all day to get enough
nutrients.
And,
and so this evolutionary theory is that
we learned to extract and harvest much
more nutrient dense foods from animals,
fats and,
and other nutrients in the meats and
organ meats.
And we had,
we could then spend a lot less of our
time going around getting food which
allowed us and then develop bigger
brains and you know,
become human and have this conversation
where we're talking about a vegetarian
and Vegan diets.
Yeah.
It is kind of interesting.
And it's also important to differentiate
the difference between what you're
saying is essentially the science behind
the development of the human animal
versus the moral and ethical debates
that lead environmental and
environmental debates.
Which is awesome.
We can,
we can,
we can talk about that too.
Which would,
which is what influences people to
become vegetarians and vegans,
which I totally respect.
I understand what they're saying.
The real problem is when they distort
the reality of the scientific findings,
the human animal and diet.
And that's an issue with a lot of people
that are vegetarians and vegans that go
on about how healthy they feel and about
how awesome,
but they're not doing blood lipid
profiles and when they do like Sam
Harris,
who is from an ethical perspective for
ethical reasons,
just tried Vegan diet and his health is
suffering.
He's giving real issues with his blood
lipids.
What can someone do if they want to
follow that diet?
Like what,
what is imperative as far as healthy
fats as far as getting,
making sure that your body doesn't have,
you're not taking in too many simple
carbohydrates,
like what,
what,
what steps need to be taken place and
this is obviously not saying that you
shouldn't follow a Vegan diet,
it shouldn't follow a vegetarian diet
and you do whatever you want to do,
but there's gotta be some ways to
mitigate some of the health
consequences,
right?
Yeah,
there are.
And I believe that I agree with you that
people should be free to make their own
choices.
I've never pushed a particular diet.
You know,
people sometimes ask me,
how do you convince someone to go Paleo?
I said,
I don't,
I don't spend my time doing that.
If,
if someone wants my advice and asked me,
I'll give it to them,
but we're not going around,
you know,
proselytizing for a particular way of
eating.
Um,
so yeah,
let's break this down.
We talked about the evolutionary
argument for eating animal products and
there's a scientific argument which now
is what we're talking about,
the issue with [inaudible],
we should even kind of distinguish
between vegetarian and Vegan diets
because they're actually quite different
and I think it is possible for some
people to be healthy with a vegetarian
diet.
I think it's a lot less likely with a
Vegan diet and I guess I would say it
this way.
Um,
if you have,
if you're Vegan and you're eating a
Vegan Diet,
you need to have a perfect vegan diet to
be healthy and you need to know what
you're doing in terms of supplementation
and how to meet the nutrient needs that
aren't being met through diet.
And it,
at least in my experience,
there are very few that actually do it
right.
Um,
when it's done right,
I think it's possible for some people to
be,
to be healthy and thrive.
And that's obvious because there are
people like rich roll who's out there.
He's a Vegan triathlete who's out there
doing centuries and killing it,
ultra marathon.
He,
he is just an amazing athlete and he's
Vegan and so,
you know,
you can't say that it's not working for
it and if you try to say that you're
going to,
it looks like he's 30.
He's like,
yeah,
he's a,
he's a great guy.
I've met him a couple times.
Um,
and uh,
so certainly it works for some people,
but there are a lot of factors that
determine whether it's gonna work.
So one is,
is how well you do it.
I'm too is you know,
whether you know,
what you're dealing with supplementation
in terms of getting the necessary
nutrients.
Three is genetics.
So let me,
there are genetic differences that
determine how well we convert precursor
nutrients into the nutrients that we
actually need.
And let me give three examples to make
this more real.
So one is EPA and Dha.
These are these long chain Omega three
fats that we've heard so much about that
are crucial for brain function,
cardiovascular function,
etc.
And we primarily,
you get them by eating fish.
There Are no sources of those in a plant
based diet except for algae.
Um,
but an lg is not the bioavailable.
Right?
And how many people do you know that eat
algae?
Not.
I don't know.
You can,
you can.
There's that famous green
supplementation stuff.
That's okay.
You can use it as a supplement,
but very few people are eating it.
So,
um,
but,
but there is something called alpha
linolenic acid,
which is in walnuts and flax seed.
That's an omega three plant fat and
humans in theory can convert some of
that plant based omega three into this
long chain epa and dha that we need.
But the thing,
here's the thing,
only about five to 10 percent of that
gets converted into epa and even less to
dha,
like two to five percent.
So you have to be chugging tablespoons
of flax oil in order to get as much epa
or dha that you would get from eating
just a little bit of fish.
And that's if everything is going well
because if you have deficiency of any
nutrients that are involved in the
enzymatic conversion of those plant
based fats into the long chain fats,
then you won't make those conversions at
that optimal rate.
IT'll be even less and ironically many
of those nutrients and nutrients that
are not well represented in a vegan or
vegetarian diet.
So that's one example.
Another would be vitamin k two,
which is a,
uh,
a different form of vitamin k that's
recently been discovered and it's really
important for cardiovascular and bone
health.
It basically puts,
make sure that calcium gets in our bones
and our teeth and our heart tissues
where it belongs and keeps it out of the
soft tissues like our arteries,
where calcium would make our arteries
heart and increase the risk of a heart
attack.
So I'm two is only really in animal
foods with the exception of some
fermented foods like natto,
which is a japanese fermented soybean
product that most people cannot stand.
Um,
it's,
it's a strong taste.
Not very many people are eating it here,
a kefir and,
and sauerkraut and kimchi.
You have k,
k,
two in.
It could fear.
I've been dot kiefer my whole life.
That's how I've never heard it sets how
they say it,
where firas from every other person I've
ever met so says key.
So don't worry about it.
Okay.
I'm saying kaffir from now,
ari shaffir fear you'll be in the select
few that know how to feel good about it
already.
So yes,
you can feel superior now.
Can I stop you real quick just because
we're gonna want to get a little bit
onto this track of what you were
describing.
Fish oil conversion and the difference
between flax seed oil.
What convenience take in order to sort
of recommend that vegans take micro
algae because it has preformed dha in
it.
So you bypass that whole conversion
issue.
If they do take micro algae,
is that sufficient or how much different
is that than eating fish?
Well,
it's quite different because fish have a
lot of other nutrients aside from epa
and dha team,
they have salinium.
Um,
they have a lot of other bioavailable
nutrients.
But,
but,
and the other disadvantages,
you have to take a boatload of,
of algae.
Boatload give me a call.
I think so there are different products
have different amounts.
But um,
you know,
I think you'd have to take six to nine
caps capsules a day of the average algae
supplement in order to meet your dha.
That's not bad.
No,
it's absolutely possible,
but that would be a good way to be
healthy with the vegan diet.
That would be one way to address the
shortcoming of know of lack of dha on
the vegan diet.
There are other shortcomings,
other nutrients like b 12,
which are shoe.
That's a big issue and vegans need to be
supplementing with that.
TheRe's a myth out there that there are
some plant sources of b12 like seaweed
and in spirit like spirulina and
nutritional yeast,
but those actually contain a kind of
phony forms of b 12 that,
that can block the absorption of true
b12,
which is only found in animal products
or supplements.
So a 12 supplement would be really
important as well.
It's the source of a b 12 supplement.
Um,
they,
it's synthetic,
it's synthetic I think,
but they just,
there's three forms of be 12,
there's,
there's hydroxocobalamin and
methylcobalamin or,
or four forms that you can supplement
with cyanocobalamin and
adenosylcobalamin and cyanocobalamin is
a synthetic form.
And then the other ones are natural
forms of b,
12 that you would encounter in food.
So people can supplement with any of
those,
the natural forms,
they're better to supplement with
because they're more bioavailable.
But definitely if a vegan,
I would recommend supplementing with b
12 because there aren't any sources of
it in the diet.
And studies have shown that 68 percent
of vegetarians are deficient in b,
12.
80 three percent of vegans are versus
just five percent of omnivores.
Wow.
So it's a big difference.
We're not,
you know,
and that's a factor in,
in many different issues,
right?
It's A factor in the production of
muscle,
uh,
all production of all red blood cells
depends on [inaudible] and full eight.
And so I mean that's pretty fundamental,
right?
And then the myelin sheath requires be
12.
And this is why b,
12 deficiency can mimic the signs of
parkinson's or alzheimer's to these
people who are aging.
B,
12 deficiency happens in elderly people,
not because they're on a vegan diet beat
because they have low stomach acid and
they don't absorb the b12 as well as we
do when we're younger.
And so a lot of people who are elderly
who have symptoms of parkinson's or
alzheimer's,
they can sometimes be misdiagnosed with
these conditions when they're actually
just be 12 deficient.
So it's a series.
It's a real,
really important nutrient.
Now,
how can a vegans be assured that the
[inaudible] that they're buying does not
have a animal products?
Uh,
do,
do they have betweeN when you bind the
supplement fat typically it's usually
safe.
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm not the best person to ask about
that because I'm,
I'm not a vegan myself.
I was a macrobiotic vegan at one point.
What does that mean?
What's the difference?
That's deep.
It's like a macrame.
Macrobiotics is a,
is a whole nother system of way of
looking at food.
It's a job,
You know,
japanese,
uh,
approach and um,
you know,
the whole reason I came to do what I'm
doing now.
So I goT really,
really sick in my twenties.
I almost died and I spent about 10 years
just trying to get back to health.
And what did you pick from?
I was in Indonesia.
I mentioned earlier,
I'd traveled around the world.
I was surfing and I got the classic
tropical illness,
like immediate dysentery,
giardia and blast assistance,
hominis so to parasites and an amoeba
and was just,
you know,
coming out of both ends,
delirious,
didn't remember really anything for
three days.
Um,
luckily there was one other australian
guy in the village that I was in who had
some antibiotics and this medical kit
that kind of brought me back from the
brink,
but between the parasites and then the
multiple rounds of antibiotics I had to
take to get rid of the parasites after
that,
it just wreaked havoc on my gut and it
took me basically 10 years to recover.
Oh yeah,
10 years.
It was like the last decade when I was
at 10 years because you approached it
incorrectly and you could do it now or
was
it just such a devastating round of
disease?
I think a little of both.
I mean I'm 42 now and I was 25 when this
first happened and we didn't know
anything about the gut and the
microbiome compared to what we know now.
Like there was very little awareness on
that point.
Yeah.
Just in 15 years,
it's just,
or 20 years,
it's,
it's crazy.
So,
you know,
I Took way more antibiotics than I would
have done in retrospect because that's
what the doctors were prescribing and
saying,
look,
you've got these parasites,
we got to get rid of them.
This is how you do it and you know,
and I think the antibiotics if could
have been like the treatment was
probably worse than the disease for me
at that,
you know,
after the number of courses of
antibiotics that I took.
So along that path I tried to spell
everY special diet you can possibly
imagine including becoming a vegetarian
and a vegan and then a macrobiotic vegan
and raw food vegan.
I've been there,
done that and I'm.
so I'm completely sympathetic like to
all.
And I'm also a longtime meditater in
buddhist.
So I understand the ethical argument
very well.
Many of my friends don't eat meat.
I'm sympathetic and I'm,
I,
I care about the environment.
I'm sympathetic to that argument.
I'm certainly not,
you know,
I'm coming to this from a place of I
think a pretty balanced viewpoint.
Um,
and uh,
the,
the issues for me,
the reason why I eventually brought
animal products back into my diet was
that I,
I,
it became clear that I needed to do that
for my own health and I was able to
reach a level of understanding and a
about the moral,
ethical and environmental choices that I
was making.
Um,
that,
that I felt good about.
Sam has brought up mollusks.
He was saying that one option that
vegans might want to consider is
mollusks and that mollusks mollusks
mollusks what a weird word,
clams,
mussels.
Things along those lines are so
primitive that the argument can be made
that although they have movement where
they open and close,
that they lacked pain sensors.
They lack,
like the fundamental things that make us
distinguish the difference between
animal and plant life and that people
might want to consider the consumption
of mollusks same way they consider it.
People eat mushrooms,
mushrooms which are in a vegan diet or
healthy or closer to an animal than they
are to a plant.
They actually take in oxygen.
They breathe out carbon dioxide and
fundamentally they reSemble living
organisms that we consider like animals
more than they consider plants more than
they resemble places.
Really
good point.
And it starts,
the lines start to get blurry because we
know that some plants,
for example,
when they recognize that they're being
eaten by a,
they secrete toxins to protect
themselves,
not just recognize that they're being
eaten,
but they've played recordings of the
caterpillar eating a plant next to a
plant and it's changed the actual taste
of the leaves to the point where animals
find them disgusting and it causes some
animals to starve to death.
Not some level of awareness.
I mean,
you may not call that intelligence or
sanctions,
but it's some,
you know,
what's the difference there between um,
a mollusk for example,
who,
that like you described blAcks,
pain sensors and you know,
what should we be prioritizing in that
situation if we are,
if we're using an ethical argument
against eating meat,
there's even thornier issue,
which is there's no system of food
production that does not involve the
death of animals,
it and.
correct.
So if you think about monocropping big,
you know tiller with blades going
through these fields,
you're killing vols,
you're killing rabbits,
you're killing snakes,
you're killing all kinds of small
animals and is the value of a small
animal life less than the value of a
large animal life.
Some philosophers or people who look at
this morally have actually argued that
killing a larger before like a cow that
can feed many people is superior
ethically or morally.
Then you know a method of food
production that kills many small animals
in order to,
you know,
and won't feed as many people can.
People treat density per.
Don't like to look at that
because it's inconvenient.
But I have friends that I have a good
buddy of mine who has a farm in Iowa and
he says when they run the combines over
corn and grain and chopped down all the
different things that they grow.
You'll see vultures and crows and all
these things circling the fields because
there's all sorts of animals that get
chewed up in that process.
And in fact,
more animals get chewed up to create a
pound of grain.
Like more animals,
more more insects,
more,
I mean when insects are animals by the
way,
there are a life form and more different
things get chewed up in creating that
then would be if you've got a pound of
meat,
because as you said,
one cow could to consolidate.
A lot of people consume it over the
course of a year and
the nutrient density is far superior to
a pound of grains or even an equivalent
amount of weight
grains,
which you don't hear that argument.
You hear the opposite argument where a
cow consumes so much grass,
it needs so much land to graze and that
argument,
unfortunately it's actually been
distorted.
I had some guys on from the documentary
cowspiracy,
which I don't think they were
intentionally trying to deceive.
I think they're really good guys and
they're making,
they're,
they think they're making a really good
point,
but when you talk to ranchers and you
get the actual number of how much
acreage it takes to feed a cow,
it's not as much as they thought it was.
No,
we can talk about that too.
Um,
the,
the interest to ethical argument is
really interesting too for all of these
reasons,
but then you think about the method of
death,
right?
So let's take like a,
a humane slaughterhouse where there's a
lot of care and consideration that goes
into how the animals last moments are
and how they actually slaughter the
animals so that it's painless and quick.
I can hear the vegans going crazy right
now.
This is jumbo shrimp.
This is military intelligence is versus
let's see this,
this combine that goes through the field
decapitates the mother vole and her
babies in the nest die of starvation
because their mother is not able to
provide food for them.
That's a,
that's a arguably worse way for an
animal to die.
Right?
Or even any of your rancher friends know
what it's like,
you know,
they found one of their animals that's
been killed by a predator.
And if you go on youtube and watch how
like a hyena kill an animal to animal
will still be alive while it's getting
disemboweled yeah,
that's not a very nice way to die.
Right?
And that's what wolves will do.
And that's what I mean,
that's a,
that's a giant issue.
The difference between the way a
predator kill something in the way a
person does,
but on the other hand,
of course it's impossible to deny the
real issues with factory farming and the
inhumane methods that are so common when
you're buying these chicken nuggets.
I guarantee you these are not ethically
sourced ethically and humanely raised
chickens.
They're just not and know when you're
driving on the highway and you see those
trucks that are stuffed full of chickens
and the chickens literally the little
faces or poking out of the side of the
truck that,
that,
that is in my opinion,
a bigger issue.
Absolutely.
And this is,
I mean,
interestingly enough,
this is something where I think I have
more in common with vegans than I do
with like the average person is we both
care about how food is produced.
We care about,
you know,
I don't eat factory farmed meat.
I don't eat factory farmed vegetables.
You know,
like I,
I try to eat meat that's from local,
from local farmer.
I'm lucky that where I live,
that that's accessible.
Um,
I buy produce from the farmers market,
we grow a lot of produce in our
backyard.
Um,
it's this whole food system that needs
to change both in terms of conventional
agriculture and the monocropping of
wheat and corn and,
and,
and these kinds of and soybeans and
plant foods,
but also the,
you know,
mass production,
conventional,
um,
a animal operations need to change as
well.
So I'm not arguing for that.
And I think that's absolutely a losing
argument,
but there is a lot of land that two
thirds of the surface land in this in
the world is not suitable for crop
production and we,
but it is suitable for raising animals.
And,
and if those animals are raised in a
sustainable way,
um,
it,
I think it is possible to feed the world
with,
you know,
maybe not the amount of animal products
that the average american is eating now.
But,
uh,
we can utilize the available land in a
much smarter way to produce nutrient
dense foods.
And we just,
you know,
we need to consider the whole cycle.
Like we,
we like to remove ourselves from the
cycle of life and from nature.
We're not animals,
we're humans or separate from it.
But when you consider that whole cycle
and when you consider like the soil,
for example,
if you think you think of it as a bank
account,
when you plant crops,
you're withdrawing from that bank
account and if you want the soil to be
healthy and continue to be able to
support life,
you need to put input.
You need To make a deposit back in that
bank account.
And the way we've been doing that in
conventional agriculture is with,
is with chemicals and thOse chemical
fertilizers,
they do kind of make a deposit in some
way,
but they also make it less the soil,
less able to sequester carbon.
They cause all kinds of problems with
runoff and gi toxicity and water and
local watershed systems.
Um,
and any organic farmer will tell you
that the best way to add those inputs
back in is the poop of animals along
with their blood and their bone.
And so that's that cycle of life where
the animal inputs go into the soil.
Those inputs,
you know,
the urine adds water to the soil,
the poop ads,
microorganisms that help the soil
sequester carbon so that studies have
shown that pasture raised animals are
either net neutral in terms of carbon
out put her,
they actually even help sequester carbon
so you could even argue that raising
animals and eating animals is necessary
for the benefit of our soils and our
ecosystems in general yet,
so if someone has has a,
a large,
you know,
20 acre plot of land and the using it to
grow alfalfa or something that people
eat or soybeans or something along those
lines.
If they're not in some way contributing
some sort of animal product to that
soil,
the soil is going to become
nutritionally deficient and then the
people who eat the plants that come out
of that soil are going to get
nutritionally deficient.
Plants minerally deficient in particular
that it's a giant issue with the United
States farmlands.
There's a booklet.
It's received a lot of criticism,
but it brings up some interesting
points.
It's called dead doctors don't lie.
It's this guy dr joel wallach and a lot
of is the things that he said have been
rightly criticized,
but what's interesting about what he's
saying is when he's talking about
minerally deficient plants and soil and
that the United States is known,
you know,
when they've done studies on farm lands
in the 19 thirties and forties,
that there was an issue with mineral
deficiency and so,
um,
that's where they started adding
nitrogen and from,
from the hopper method,
you know,
in,
into soil and it helps and you can grow
crops,
but the difference between the food that
you're getting that is grown with
chemical fertilizers that address sOme
of the issues that you're talking abouT
versus the traditional method of compost
and manure and animal products.
Like you're getting away healthier plant
and when you're consuming it,
you're getting a far more nutrient dense
plant.
Right?
Not to mention the environmental
implications of chemical fertilizers.
Pesticides,
I know dial got bone cancer because he
grew up next to a golf course and the
pesticides and all the shit that they
would pump onto thE golf course to keeP
the weeds from growing.
Got into the well system And a bunch of
people in this community like a huge
amount got cancer,
right.
I want to go back to something you were
saying about,
you know,
vegans and vegetarians anD how to kind
of optimize if you're doing that diet.
So,
um,
two things that I wanted to address.
One was you asked about mollusks and
that I've actually argued that a
vegetarian diet with shellfish and organ
meats would be better than a paleo diet
with no shellfish and organ meats.
Interesting.
And that's Because what we talked about
earlier,
muscle meats,
organ meats and shellfish are the two
most nutrient dense classes of foods.
Like I,
I've just been finishing the curriculum
for my clinician training program where
I'm going through systematically every
nutrient and I'm looking at in nutrition
data what the most,
the highest food sources for those
nutrients are.
And again,
I wish I had the thing to just lay it
out and show you.
But you know,
in almost every case it's an organ meat
or a shellfish.
that's the highest source of that.
Whether you're talking about 12 or iron
or copper or zinc or full eight,
it's always beef,
liver,
chicken,
clams,
oysters,
et cetera.
And so if someone was a veggie
vegetarian who was willing to fudge a
little bit and eat organ meats and
shellfish,
I think that would be a healthier
approach than someone who's just eating
lean muscle.
Neat.
Um,
organs get tossed out a lot.
It's a really.
It's a real problem in the hunting world
where when people got an animal,
they leave the gut pile and there's even
a gutless method that a lot of people
use when they,
uh,
they take on a big game animal,
like an elk or something like that.
They just,
they leave it behind.
They leave the heart,
they leave the liver.
But I saw this documentary on wolves and
was really fascinating was one of the
ways that they distinguish who the alpha
is.
In the wolf pack is the alpha wolf is
the one who eats the liver the liver
faster.
There are other animals that that's
true.
And I think that was true in hunter
gather societies as well.
And someone was trying to say to me,
well,
we'll livers process toxins,
don't you think they'd be filled with
toxins?
That's a common misconception.
The liver processes then,
but the,
the fat stores them.
So if you're concerned about toxins in
food,
you should make sure that you're eating,
you know,
pasture raised,
organic fats like butter and cream and
thing.
If you dairy products,
animal fats,
grass fed,
grass fed butter,
if you eat lard or tallow or anything
like that,
it should come from pasture raised
animals because the fat is where toxins
are stored.
The liver processes.
then,
um,
so when you,
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but so when you're eating anything that
comes from an animal that's been fed
grain,
you're dealing with an animal that has
the same sort of inflammation issuEs
that a Person hAs from processing things
that it's not naturally supposed to
process.
Like pat processed wheat and the
bleached flour and things besides
antibiotic residue.
Yeah.
So when you're taking in those animal
products that we traditionally do,
whether it's butter or milk or dairy or
cheese or things along those lines,
when you're taking those from an animal
that's eating grain,
you're actually getting the fats.
So your,
your,
it's less healthy than actually eating
the liver of that animal.
Yeah,
I would.
It may be.
I mean the liver is more nutrient dense
anyways.
But um,
pasture raised animal fats a have a lot
more nutrients than conventionally
raiseD fats because the animals are
eating grass and grasses way more
nutrient dense than the grains that,
you know,
conventional animals are fed.
Also,
the omega threes and sixes are
different.
The ratio a mega six is the same,
but omega three is three or four times
higher in pasture raised animals.
Why does it make it six percent?
It's a good question.
It's,
it used to be the kind of a consensus
was that omega sixes would be higher in
omega threes will be lower,
but it actually looks like omega six is
constant and omega three is higher.
The omega three is higher because of the
grass probably has more alpha linolenic
acid,
which is the plant based form,
uh,
that day.
Then animal does the conversion.
I mean,
that's the thing that's really
interesting to,
to consider here too is humans are
really inefficient at making these
conversions of these less active
nutrients to the more active ones.
We started talk about it with epa and
dha,
k,
vitamin k,
one is what's converted into k two cows
are experts at doing that.
They're really good at it.
HumanS not so much.
So when we eat the animal,
the animals basically done the work for
us.
We get the preformed final nutrient that
we need rather than having to do those
steps ourselves and starting to rub is,
is this a function of the adaptation of
people developing while eating these
animals?
I think so,
yeah.
A beta carotenes another example that's
a precursor to active vitamin a or
retinol and beta carotenes have some
benefits in our bodies,
but retinols is the real thing.
You know,
what we need more than anything.
And uh,
that conversion is as low as three to
five percent.
And some people on facts there,
there are some who don't make the
conversion at all and those are the
people who turn orange after a carrot
juice fast,
ever see me when I'm with like the
orange palms.
but it happens.
My friend andy used to drink so much
characteristic the inside of his hands
and his skin would turn orange so he
probably wasn't good at converting beta
carotene into retinol because we should
be able to do that.
But some people can't but isn't just the
mass quantities.
I mean it could be that too,
but I'm a retinol is only really present
in organ meats and pasture raised fats.
It's not even really in muscle meats
like,
you know,
lean ground beef or chicken breast,
boneless chicken breast or um,
so in order to get retinol we need to
consume these pasture raise.
Fats are where we need to consume organ
meats.
And as you pointed out,
we're going to be.
It's really fallen out of favor in the
us.
And this is only recent,
like I bet you our grandparents ate a
lot more organ meats than we eat still
in some parts of the world.
They still eat organ meats more try.
We do liver and onions are very famous
dish.
Yeah.
It's hard.
And so you'll see like within the paleo,
primal kind of world,
the organ meats are making a comeback
because we understand now with the
nutrient density of these foods is and
there's less now even in the mainstream
world,
there's less of a solid argument that
can be made about these having
cholesterol or high levels of saturated
fat.
It would prevent us from meeting them
now,
will it be the difference in terms of
the nutritional density of mollusks
versus organ meat?
So like if you were trying,
if you had a vegetarian or a vegan who's
on the fence and you know,
you made these arguments that are very
rational and logical and you said it,
look,
mollusks are essentially a very,
very primitive form of life that doesn't
feel pain.
And you could argue that there's more
evidence that some plants feel pain and
plants also have some very intense level
of communication where there,
there's a really interesting,
uh,
addition of radio lab recently where
they went into this were they sort of
are trying to understand the difference
between,
uh,
the,
not the difference rather,
but the,
the complicated relationship between
these different plants and the mycelium
in the soil and all of the different
fungus in the soil that also acts as
sort of a transportation method.
The various nutrients and minerals.
And they're actually pulling these
minerals out of the rock and they're
getting sugars from the plants and
they're exchanging them for minerals.
And that there's this really complex
interaction that we have sort of just
looked at and said,
oh,
there's dirt.
There's plants in it.
But there's a lot going on between these
various life forms.
And one of them being fungus,
which again is closEr to an animal than
it is to a PlAnt,
but is imperative for the life of these
plants.
AnD then somehow know that there were
actually even sharing resources where if
they find or they're allotting resources
to certain plants that are more
deficient or they're trying to channel
resources to them.
So there's some form of communication
and exchange here.
Yeah,
that's,
that's intelligence,
right?
I mean,
paul stamets has done amazing work on
this youngest in.
Yeah,
I would say that that's a really good
option.
I mean,
when you look at nutrients like specific
nutrients that it goes back and forth
between liver and,
you know,
organ meats and shellfish and some,
some nutrients.
A organ meats are higher like vitamin a
or iron and other nutrients.
Shellfish are generally higher like with
zinc or copper.
Um,
but certainly even,
even a shellfish are higher in almost
all of the key nutrients that we need.
Then a lot of the plant based food
alternatives that they would be choosing
from.
And so if it's a vegan was willing to
eat molluscs I would say that that would
be a great idea.
And,
and,
uh,
the benefit there is you don't need to
eat a lot,
like three ounces,
a single serving a can meet your copper
requirement for the entire week.
Oh wow.
just one time.
Waste oysters and I've history and same
with iron.
I think if I'm going off the top of my
head,
I'll iron and zinc.
It can nearly meet your entire weekly
requirement.
So it's not like you have to eat a ton
of these things.
You,
you know,
you have a serving of clams once a week
and you have a serving of oysters once a
week,
uh,
you know,
on top of the,
uh,
getting as much nutrient density as you
can,
that should do,
that'll be 12.
That's iron that sink.
That's copper,
epa and dha.
The launching of omega three fats are in
these,
uh,
in these mollusks because as well,
and they're typically low on the
toxicity,
a scale to.
They're not,
they don't tend to hAve a lot of
mercury.
They don't bio accumulate a lot of
toxins compared to some other predator
species of fish that are higher in the
food chain that accumulated a lot of
toxins.
Is there any benefit to eating them
cooked versus raw one way or the other?
Well,
you know,
there's all,
there is the chance of disease in eating
raw oysters.
Um,
I think it's pretty minimal compared to
some other risks,
but it is there and cooking,
you know,
mitigates that.
So definitely I think in general cooking
makes the nutrients in meat and animal
products more bioavailable rather than
less.
Uh,
and that's in vegetables.
It's,
it depends on the vegetable and the um,
and the method of cooking.
But a,
it,
it's a mix.
It's more of a mixed bag,
but with me to generally improve the
bioavailability.
So it really is in a lot of ways an
ideological issue where it's sort of
framed that,
you know,
you don't want to contribute to
suffering,
but these things really don't suffer
there.
Yeah.
But even there,
you know,
as we talked about,
you're going to control,
you're gonna contribute to suffering and
potentially more if you're looking on
the scale of individual lives,
and it might sound like this is
nitpicky,
but it's not.
we're talking about actual lives,
you know,
and,
and then you have to start evaluating
like is a cow more attention or worth
the life of the cow worth more than the
life of a rabbit or a
fall or the kind of animals that are
being killed.
And you know,
in the production of these plant foods,
um,
it's a real question.
And then you have insecticides and you
have,
you know,
the amount of insects that get her
killed.
Killed.
yeah.
When you're processing crops,
there's just no getting around.
If you're buying anything that is from
large scale agriculture,
you were involved in the death of some
sort of animals or insects.
And I know the argument is like,
there's an argument about intentionality
and whether,
you know,
if,
if I intended to kill this animal to eat
it,
it's different than if you didn't intend
to eat it.
To me that's,
I'm not so sure about that.
Yeah,
because it's,
it's almost like willful ignorance that,
that,
um,
that these animals are being killed in
the production of these plants that I'm
eating.
I mean,
I see the argument,
but I'm not sure I buy it.
I do as well.
And I see the willful ignorance argument
up until the point where it gets
explained to you.
So as soon as someone explained to you
like you've just done about the combines
and how they're chewing up all these
animals.
And by the way fonz too,
it's a huge issue with deers because if
you've ever seen a baby deer out in the
wild,
there's one of the weirdest things about
them.
When they're very young,
they do not move.
So in the face of danger,
they have this instinct freeze so you
can literally go up to a fawn and
they'll,
they'll be tucked up on the ground and
they're healthy,
completely healthy.
And you could walk right next to the
font and the headlights.
Yeah.
You could stomp on the ground next to
them.
They don't move.
They sit around and wait for their
mother to retail.
It's really interesting.
They get chewed up by combines.
It's really.
I mean because these animals bed in
these fields all the time and if
something happens to the mother,
especially if she gets attacked by a
coyote or something along those lines
and then the babies just get chewed up
by the,
by the combines.
There's,
yeah.
There's another interesting question
here too,
which is more around like privilege and
again like whether we see ourselves as
part of the ecosystem and the food cycle
or as separate from it.
Did you think about like native american
or traditional hunter gather or even
contemporary people living in let's say
in Afghanistan and all they can they
have is a goat,
you know,
and they.
Or a poor family in India who has access
to a backyard cow,
should they not eat,
you know,
milk and butter and those animal foods
because of moral or ethical argument
against that,
or it seems like an argument coming from
a tremendous place of privilege for,
for us to,
to say that the choices that they make
are somehow wrong or immoral because
they,
you know,
we can afford to make these different
choices in defense of vegans.
I never hear that argument honestly.
I see.
I think I hear the argument that in
America today you have the choice and in
westernized you have the choice
and so that you can choose to contribute
less to suffering,
which I think ideologically makes a lot
of sense.
The problem is when you deal with the
reality of it that you've sort of
described about large scale agriculture,
you're not.
It means you're not immune to the
suffering of animals in the death.
It's just,
it's just not the case.
Especially when you talk about insects.
I mean it's just,
there's no way.
It's just an insects,
at least.
I mean,
in my mind are more complex and more
complicated than mollusks.
Yeah,
I mean certainly the,
if you look at some of the studies on an
insect behavior,
that's,
I think that would be born out.
Yeah.
But we have these like weird hierarchy,
so we love bees.
Bees are super important.
These are another species that gets
totally decimated by factory farming.
Pesticides.
Pesticides are really,
really harmful for the bees.
Um,
yeah.
I mean I agree with you.
I think there is,
you can say we have this because we have
that privilege.
We have the imperative not to cause more
suffering,
but I think what I get out of looking at
those cultures is it's more clear to me
how intertwined with with nature and the
natural food systems that humans are in
those circumstances,
they're less removed from the basic
cycle of life and it,
it seems natural.
And when you,
you know,
for the mussai pastoralist people to,
to,
to drink the blood of the cows and eat
and drink the milk and eat the meat
because that's inexorably intertwined to
their culture and their way of life.
So that's why they survived.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
you know,
I think this is a really nuanced,
complex topic and there's a lot more to
it than is typically shows up in the
internet debates of that.
Just go back and forth.
But at the end of the day,
from what I've seen as a clinician
working with a lot of patients,
a lot of ex vegans,
a lot of ex vegetarians,
is that some people can pull it off for
a relatively long period of time and I
think this is because they have the
genes and the preexisting nutrient
status and allows them to make those
conversions of a less active nutrients
to the more active forms.
I'm better than the average person.
Then you see someone who goes on a vegan
diet and falls apart within a couple of
months and this is the person who does
not have the genes to make the,
you know,
they're poor converter and they also
probably had preexisting nutrient
deficiencies which made them less able
to make those conversions.
and so this kind of solves the question
of,
or addresses the question you hear some
people say,
well,
why does that person,
that person does a vegan diet?
And he's pretty healthy,
you know,
like you're rich roll.
Um,
so it can't be,
can't be problematic.
Well,
look,
we don't all respond the same way to the
same choices.
Yeah,
of course.
BIo,
the,
the difference in
the way human beings respond to various
foods can obviously be exhibited really
quickly and easily with allergies.
Food allergies,
absolutely.
How many people,
I mean,
we all know someone who has,
like my friend brian,
his mother,
if she eats a Brazil nut,
she's dead and she will chew those
things all day and nothing happens other
than I get bored with them,
especially if she has to pay 600 bucks
for an epi pen.
Yeah.
There's a lot of different things that
show the biodiversity of just human
beings when we come from different parts
of the world.
Our ancestors came from different parts
They developed and evolved under
different diets.
And that's where I think paleo is kind
of fallen like a.
Maybe has been less successful as a
concept then it could have been
otherwise.
I really believe there's no one size
fits all approach to diet or life in
general.
But um,
you know,
if you take two different people,
for example,
like a off a person who is primarily
sedentary,
it works in an office,
60 pounds overweight,
you know,
prediabetic,
um,
you know,
not doing really any physical activity.
And then you take someone like Michael
Phelps who's super athlete training,
you know,
burning calories every day.
It's clear.
It's clear to me that they're going to
need a completely different dietary
approach.
Even if we talk about within a certain
template or are,
you know,
choice of foods,
Michael Phelps is going to need a lot
more carbohydrate.
He's going to need lot higher calorie
intake in general.
He's going to need more nutrients.
He's gonna need to be eating more
regularly.
You know,
intermittent fasting is not going to
work for him probably.
Um,
but it's amazing to me how often that is
completely left out of the equation.
When,
when,
when there's discussion of diets,
you see,
you know,
the books on everyone should be on a low
fat diet.
Then the next crazy low carb,
everyone,
you know,
carbs are toxic.
We shouldn't eat carbs and then you
know,
everyone should be on paleo and never
touched another grain or lagoon or dairy
product for the rest of their life.
You know,
that's just stupid.
That's not the way it works is really
important when you're talking about
people like ultra marathon runners or
people like Michael Phelps or just
burning off massive amounts of calories.
When you think about how much energy is
involved in those sprints that he's
doing across the pool and the training
for those,
which is just unbelieVably grueling.
Yeah.
I read this thing about him eating like
several pizzas at night and you look at
him and he's shredded.
It doesn't zero body fat,
like obviously his body's doing
something with that.
It's kind of important.
I think that is very important.
Also when you're talking about sedentary
lifestyles,
contributing to diseases and in factors
like high blood pressure and clogging of
the arteries and you're just,
your,
your body is less likely to be healthy
when you're not doing much with it,
period.
AbSolutely.
And uh,
I mean,
I think that can work both ways.
On the one hand,
phelps would probably be better off
choosing a different calorie source than
pizzas,
you know,
arguably,
I don't know.
But uh,
so he can get away with a lot more than
I can say that he shouldn't be doing
anything differently than what is the
most successful swimmer.
Isn't he like the most successful
olympian?
I think.
Yeah.
I don't think anyone's one any more gold
medal.
So what the heck do I know?
Just keep on doing whatever you're
doing.
It's working.
Um,
no,
but I think genes play a role,
you know,
for sure you take a coming back to
people like michael are rich,
like I think rich could probably eat,
almost,
could have a lot of different diets and
still be and still be phenomenal.
I've had rich on the podcast before and
he sort of explained his transition to
being a vegan and it came from being
really unhealthy and eating terrible,
piss poor diet,
eating super healthy and eating a really
nutrient dense vegetables constantly and
only that primarily and you know,
obviously had a massive benefit from
changing from the standard american diet
that you outlined to this vegan diet.
Right.
MAkes you wonder what he,
you know,
what might have happened if he had done
switch to like a paleo diet.
Oh,
don't say that.
So nobody wants to hear that.
Right.
It's like,
it's not,
it's,
it's one of those things that gets a
hit.
There's an ideological wall that cannot
be crossed and so no one even wants to
look at the possibility of it being
physically beneficial.
You just say,
that is not an option.
I'm a vegan and this is what I do.
That's fine.
You know,
I don't,
like I said,
I'm not invested in changing anyone's
mind about that.
Nor should you be.
Yeah.
Um,
I want to go back to two things.
One thing I want to go back to was your,
you're talk about talking about fish
oil,
like the long term,
uh,
negative aspects of consuming fish oil.
Like what were those?
So,
um,
early on,
I mean the history is kind of important
to see how,
because it illustrates the number of
principles that we've been talKing
about.
So early research that,
you know,
they looked at traditionally knew it
people and said,
wow,
these people don't really have heart
disease.
What is it about their diet that could
explain this?
Wow.
They eat mostly seal blubber and they
have enormous intake of omega three
fats,
so it could be an omega three fats and
then they start doing research and they
find that there is an inverse
association between omega three fat
consumption,
like in seafood and cardiovascular
disease risk.
In other words,
people who eat more fish have fewer
heart attacks and die of cardiovascular
disease,
much less.
Okay.
So pretty promising so far.
So then it's like,
okay,
why don't we then give people fish oil
supplements?
And so they give people fish oil
supplements.
They do some,
some research on that,
that short term.
And find that yes,
there are,
there do appear to be some benefits from
fish oil supplementation,
short term,
but then over a longer period of time
and met analysis
of longer term studies.
They find that the benefits of fish oil
I've probably been significantly
overstated.
And then in fact in some cases high
doses of fish oil for an extended period
of time actually appear to cause harm.
And so there are few few important
principles here.
Number one is the the folly of looKing
at one super isolated unusual population
like the traditional in us who live in a
really marginalized environment and
looking at their diet and then
extrapolating that to us who don't live
in the arctic and don't have their diet
or lifestyle and didn't evolve.
You can evolve up there.
And,
and interestingly enough,
some recent studies have found that the
nun have certain genetic adaptations
that allow them to thrive on very high
doses of omega three,
which we don't have.
So,
so that illustrates the problem with
taking,
you know,
saying,
oh this works for the anyway,
so it should work for us.
it doesn't actually work that way.
And now we know why,
it's because of the genetics.
Um,
the second folly and this happens all
the time and it's kind of a uniquely
american thing.
It's like,
oh,
a little bit as good.
Well,
a lot must be even better.
That's me as he stares.
Is bullet proof coffee over there?
Yeah.
Um,
so yeah,
I,
uh,
I think what is becoming more clear is
that eating fish is good.
Taking really high doses of fish oil for
a long period of time may not be now
what were the negative health benefits
or the negative health effects rather
well,
an increase in cardiovascular disease
risk in some cases and increase in some
inflammatory markers.
The thing to understand about omega
three fats is they're very fragile.
so fats have different levels of
susceptibility to something called
oxidative damage,
which means a [inaudible] and they
combine with oxygen and the fat becomes
damaged and rancid and then can be
harmful.
And that's,
you know,
brief description without going into the
science.
Um,
and so saturated fats,
because they are saturated with hydrogen
atoms,
they're not susceptible to oxidative
damage and they're relatively stable.
It can tolerate the application of
temperature,
like when you cook with it or light,
you know,
so if they're stored in a clear jar,
they're not going to decompose and
become rancid.
Whereas polyunsaturated fats are,
are lacking in hydrogen atoms.
They become more susceptible to
oxidative stress.
and the most unsaturated fats are the
long chain omega three fats.
So this means that they,
this is why you don't cook,
you never hear anyone saying that you
should cook with fish oil.
You know,
if you cook with it,
you'll,
you'll damage the fats will become
rancid and oxidize.
This is why fish oil is stored in opaque
bottles to protect it from light because
if light hits it,
it will oxidize and become rancid.
And the suspicion is that if we eat,
you know,
we take these high doses of unsaturated
fat,
we actually increased the risk of
oxidative stress,
which can cause inflammation,
which in turn is the root of all chronic
disease.
So,
um,
what I advise my patients is,
you know,
just eat fish and if for some reason you
can't eat fish or won't eat fish,
then taking some,
some fish oil.
Um,
I prefer cod liver oil because it has
vitamins a and d in addition to epa and
dha,
but at a relatively low dose or moderate
dose,
you know,
maybe like a teaspoon a day,
um,
rather than going for like 20 grams or
15 grams a day of fish oil.
So the real issue is in the oxidative
stress.
So,
and also the,
the,
so the potential of something being
rancid sort of mitigates or a diminishes
all the positive benefits from it.
But if you can be assured that there was
no rancid,
well no because it can become damaged in
your body.
So there's two types of data.
It can be damaged by heat or lighting
outside of your body.
That's less of an issue because storage,
you know,
people know this,
the producers of these oils,
no it.
So they store them in,
in a opaque bottles and when you get the
fish oil,
you're instructed to put it in the
refrigerator,
preserve it,
but inside of your body,
the fats can become oxidized to.
And historically,
when you look at traditional diets,
you see that the majority of fat is,
comes from saturated or mono unsaturated
fat and there's only a small amount of
fat that comes,
it's polyunsaturated that they would get
from eating nuts or seeds which are
pretty high in polyunsaturated fats and
olives.
All of olive oil has some avocados,
has some polyunsaturated fats,
omega sixes,
um,
but there weren't,
you know,
there wasn't really an opportunity for
them to be getting really high doses of
polyunsaturated fat that you would get
from taking multiple fish oil capsules
in a day.
Um,
so that.
So that's the issue.
And that's also actually why
industrialized seed oils are bad for us.
You know,
things like corn oil,
soybean oil,
a sunflower and safflower,
like all the stuff that's in chips and
crackers and cookies and restaurant
foods primarily is that when those oils
get heated,
they become rancid.
And those rancid oils can be harmful.
Wow.
That is really important information.
You know,
it's also interesting,
you're bringing up cod liver oil that's
more like sort of ancient knowledge.
Grandma and grandpa people would have
you take a tablespoon of cod liver oil.
You build
your house.
When they were right,
we talked about retinol,
vitamin a,
the active form of vitamin a in how it's
not found in very many foods,
just organ meats and pasture raised fats
and a cod liver oil is from liver cod
livers and the oil is very high in
vitamin a.
It's also high in vitamin d,
which a lot of people are deficient in a
and it's has epa and dha.
So again,
this is traditional wisdom.
Our ancestors knew.
They had,
you know,
they may not have scientifically
understood what the benefit was,
but they,
they knew through trial and error.
That is really interesting.
Here's another thing that I wanted to
bring up that we talked about earlier.
The misconception that unsat,
that saturated fats rather saturated
fats and cholesterol are bad for you.
You know,
um,
this is something that you hear vegans
talk about all the time.
They don't do videos about it as
saturated fats are terrible for you and
it's just not true.
Yeah.
Unfortunately,
they're not current with the science.
I mean,
even the us dietary guidelines now have
no restriction on dietary cholesterol.
So the most recent version of the
dietary guidelines,
you look at him,
there is no restriction on dietary
cholesterol.
So the vegans are aligning themselves
with science that's decades old at this
point and they're out of step even with
the conventional,
totally vanilla mainstream dietary
guidelines.
I don't think they care.
I think it's an ideological thing.
Yeah.
I think this is something that they
have.
They have their bullet points and
saturated fats bad.
Yeah.
And they go to at saturated fats,
consumption of animal products,
bad cholesterol,
bad.
So this is based on,
uh,
an old understanding of how heart
disease develops,
which is kind of the pipe analogy we can
call it.
So like break it down for us,
chris,
saturated fat and cholesterol are like
gunk that clog up your pipes,
right?
That's kinda how we all were taught,
you know,
we all conceive of it.
Um,
so you eat,
you know,
a burger and egg yolks and that just
gradually will build up and you know,
as gunk in your arteries and eventually
those arteries clogged.
And the occlusion of the arteries,
this is what causes a heart attack
because blood can't get through to the
heart and it causes a,
an ischemic event,
no oxygen,
heart attack,
um,
or you know,
platforms.
And then the plaque ruptures and that in
it blocks the artery and blood can't get
to the heart and you have a heart
attack.
So that's kinda the,
the dominant idea.
And it turns out it's not actually true.
Um,
for one thing,
there was actually just a study
published that reviewed all of the
randomized clinical trials that looked
at substituting saturated
polyunsaturated fat for saturated fat.
So they took away people's butter and
gave them corn oil and soybean oil,
which I don't know how they found that
people were willing to take that trade.
But,
um,
vegans,
yeah.
This,
this was at a time where saturated fat
was seen as harmful and they probably
gave them margarine.
You know,
some
of that other stuff.
Remember when that was supposed to be
good.
I can't believe it's not butter,
right?
So terrible for you.
It's hard to find it now.
And so they reviewed 10 studies and they
found that only one supported this
notion,
one of 10 supported this notion that,
that replacing saturated fat with
polyunsaturated fat,
which was good for you,
and even that study was flawed because a
much higher percentage of people in the
control group were we're smoke were
smokers,
and um,
had some other characteristics that
would have made them more susceptible to
having heart disease independent of
whatever,
what's going on with their diet.
WaS that intentional?
No,
It was poorly designed study.
Uh,
I dunno,
I mean,
I guess it depends on whether you think
the researchers were trying to get a
particular outcome or whether you think
it was just poor design.
Um,
so there's the early studies suggested
that if you eat more saturated fat and
cholesterol,
the cholesterol level in your blood
would go up and they use that as a way
of.
And then everyone knew that high
cholesterol in your blood causes heart
attack.
So if a plus b and b plus c equals c,
then a equals c,
right?
So,
um,
but that turned out to not actually be
true on two counts.
Number one,
when they just looked at the direct
relationship between saturated fat
intake and cholesterol intake and heart
disease,
just taking blood cholesterol completely
out of the equation like let's forget
about the mechanism.
Let's just see if people who eat more
fat and cholesterol actually have more
heart attacks.
When they did those studies,
no difference.
People who eat more fat and more
cholesterol did not have more heart
attacks than people who eat less,
so that was a huge problem and then more
recent studies have found that on
average,
saturated certainly dietary cholesterol
intake has nothing to do with serum
cholesterol levels.
For the vast majority of people,
70 percent of patients won't see any
change in their diet,
in their blood cholesterol levels by
changing their dietary cholesterol
levels one way or the other,
and how do you account for the other 30?
They're called hyper responders and that
may be genetic,
so they may have a certain ape geno type
that predisposes them to be more
susceptible to the effects of dietary
cholesterol.
They may be hyper absorbers of dietary
cholesterol,
so they actually absorb more through
their gut than a typical person.
But even those hyper responders,
they found that both their total,
their total cholesterol went up,
but that was because both the good and
bad cholesterol went up at the same
time.
So the effects were seen as being not
clinically relevant because although you
saw an increase in the total,
it was driven by good going up as well
as the bad going up a little bit.
So it wasn't thought to be clinically
significant.
Is it possible that like what we're
talking about before longterm studies
would reveal more because we were
talking about a certain nutrients.
When you eliminate them from the diet,
it takes a long time to find the effect
or what we're talking about with fish
oil that maybe if a longterm study
showed an increase in dietary
cholesterol,
you can see negative effects.
Yeah.
I think long longterm studies could
certainly reveal different effects.
I think the biggest question here is
should we be looking at a blood
cholesterol levels as the sole arbiter
of whether something is good or or bad
for us?
You know what I mean?
Like let's say someone switches to a
nutrient dense low carb diet from that
standard american diet,
and let's say every single thing about
their health improves.
They lose weight,
they,
uh,
their insulin levels decrease.
Their blood sugar levels go down on
their blood pressure levels go down,
their inflammatory markers go down.
By the way,
this is not a theoretical thing.
This is something I see every day in my
practice,
but their total cholesterol goes up.
Is that a bad thing?
Is that a good thing?
You know,
should,
should they go back to the standard
american diet eating?
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but if you,
could you explain what is the difference
between bad cholesterol and good
cholesterol to the people that.
Yeah.
So this is a really big over
simplification and it was created I
think by the drug companies to make it
seem very simple.
Like,
you know,
good cholesterol,
bad cholesterol,
bad,
our drug lowers your bad cholesterol.
Good.
You know that that's how simple they
want it to be.
It's not actually that simple.
So called bad cholesterol actually has
some,
some important roles that it plays.
It wasn't actually just dare to give us
heart attacks contrary to that,
you know,
what that model would assume.
Um,
and what's even more wrong about
referring to a cholesterol is we're not
actually what's important is not really
how much cholesterol we have.
What's important is the lipoproteins.
So let me see if I can use an analogy
here.
So imagine your bloodstream is like a
highway and uh,
the cars on the highway or the
lipoproteins and the passengers in the
car are the cholesterol,
the lipoproteins carry around the body
and a lipoproteins also carry fat
soluble vitamins,
like vitamin a and vitamin d and
triglycerides and other things that,
that our body actually needs.
So they're like a taxi service that
carries cholesterol aNd fats and other
nutrients all around the body and takes
them to the cells where they're actually
used.
Okay.
So for years it was thought that the
amount of cholesterol inside the
lipoproteins was the big issue.
And that's what's measured when you go
and you get a liquid panel and uc,
you get your total cholesterol,
your ldl and your hdl cholesterol.
They're measuring the passengers in the
cars,
like how much cholesterol is inside of
those particles,
and that was thought to be the driving
factor for risk for heart disease.
We now know that it's not really the
cholesterol inside of the particles that
makes a difference.
It's how many particles you have.
So to use,
come back to this analogy.
If you have a highway and you've got a
whole bunch of cars on the highway,
it's as likely that want more likely
when I'm gonna go off the road and
crash,
right?
And they'll crash into the artery,
the site,
the endothelial wall of the artery,
and it'll damage the artery and they.
And that's what initiates this whole
process of plaque formation that
eventually leads to heart disease.
So it's literally like volume.
It's a gradient driven process.
So if you have a high number of
particles in the luminal space of the
artery,
they will try to diffuse across the
lumen.
So it was an issue with overeating.
No.
So,
uh,
so what we're talking about here is the
number of particles and all of the
things that I talked about earlier that
raised cholesterol.
What I was actually referring to is
things that raise ldl particles.
I Just didn't want to go into all of
this nuance at the risk of confusing
people.
So ldl versus hdl.
Yeah.
So you have ldl particles and you have
hdl particles.
Ldl stands for low density lipoprotein,
hdl for high density lipoprotein.
And traditionally ldl particles have
been viewed as bad.
That's the bad cholesterol.
And hdl particles have been viewed as
good and there is something,
there's definitely something to that.
The,
um,
the single most important risk factor
like marker from a,
from a blood lipid standpoint are the
two most would be l,
ldl particle number,
and another lipoprotein called
lipoprotein little a.
So I'm coming back to our analogy.
If you have a whole lot of ldl particles
are a whole lot of cars on the road,
there's more of a chance that one of
them's going to damage the artery and
then that whole process of plaque
formation is going to,
is going to occur.
And that's what increases the risk of
heart disease.
So the name of the game is to keep your
ldl particle number down.
and when we talk about the things that
increase it,
you know,
going back to early in the interview,
genetics do play a role.
diet definitely plays a role.
But then also things like thyroid
function,
infections,
inflammation and leaky gut play a role.
So it's not happening in isolation,
you know,
it's our,
it's,
once again,
we have to look at our whole health,
you know,
our diet,
how we sleep,
how we live,
whether we have infections or
inflammation or guts,
guts,
stuff going on.
And I have many patients,
I'm often guys who kind of be their only
complaint is that they have high
cholesterol and now I don't know if
they're not.
If they are,
they really are 100 percent healthy.
And that's the only complaint we test
their ldl particle number.
It's high.
They say they have no gUt issues,
they have no fatigue,
no,
no other health problems at all.
But then I test their gut and I do all
these testing and we find issues.
We address those issues and their ldl
particle drops by 30,
40,
even 50 percent sometimes.
Wow.
Which is more than you would expect from
a staton.
So.
So this again,
this is another one of those things.
It's way more nuanced than it than it's
made out to be.
And it is true that ldl particles play
an important role in the,
in how heart disease develops,
but this dominant paradigm notion that
saturated fat and dietary cholesterol
are the main things that influence our
ldl particle number is false.
My friend anthony bourdain was taking
statents cause he,
he,
he used to eat a lot when still eats a
lot and he was developing high blood
pressure and you know,
the,
all the issues that were just outlining,
he started training every day doing
brazilian jujitsu,
like got really obsessed with it.
No longer has to take stanton's right.
Changed his,
changed his cholesterol profile,
which is really kind of fascinating.
I'm sure he's eating healthier,
but to me that's a,
that's a,
that's,
that's a very strange thing.
Like what?
What is happeNing that's causing his
cholesterol to drop because of exercise
at 58.
Did he lose weight?
Lost a lot of ways.
Thirty pounds.
The fastest way you can normalize your
cholesterol profile,
a profile in your,
your really your ldl particle number,
which is even more important and your
blood pressure is weight loss,
but why is it a contributing factor?
It's just there's a whole constellation
of metabolic changes that happens when
we become overweight that include
insulin resistance and leptin resistance
of the gut issues.
you outlines all the gut issues,
inflammation,
and this creates like a glue that leads
to dyslipidemia,
which is this.
So each particles,
so we talked about this at the cars on
the road,
a car can only hold so much,
so many passengers,
right?
and if you have a lot of fats,
the fats will take up all the space and
the cars and you will need more cars to
carry a given amount of cholesterol
around the body because we need
cholesterol for sex hormone production
and other things that you mentioned
earlier in the show.
So if you have a lot of triglyceride,
a lot of fat in your liver,
the liver will maKe more ldl particles
because it needs more particles to carry
the amount of cholesterol that needs to
get around the body.
So that's actually what's happening and
that might've been too much detail,
but that's why when you're overweight
and you have more fat,
you actually have a higher ldl particle
and when you loSe weight,
the converse happens,
you,
you need fewer particles to transport
the same amount of cholesterol,
so your ldl particle will go down,
your,
uh,
insulin and leptin sensitivity will
improve,
your gut may improve also,
and your blood pressure will typically
go down because the heart doesn't need
to work as hard to pump as much blood.
It makes sense.
Um,
the,
the terminology of
bad cholesterol versus good cholesterol
is Kind of problematic,
isn't it?
Because it doesn't ldl play some sort of
beneficial roles if you don't want to
eliminate ldl?
No.
I mean,
some have argued that it should be zero,
but I don't,
I don't think that that makes much sense
biologically.
I'm one role that it plaYs is it's
antimicrobial ldl particles are
antimicrobial,
um,
so that if,
if toxins do get into the bloodstream,
like lip lipopolysaccharide for example,
a ldl particles can be,
will be manufactured to deal with that,
and that's one reason why chronic
infections increase ldl particle number
because the body is attempting to deal
with that infection and the toxins.
Um,
as I mentioned as well,
the ldl particles are like a taxi
service that carry nutrients to
different parts of the body,
fat soluble vitamins and fats liKe
triglycerides and antioxidants too that
we need to function properly.
So I think it's a question of balance.
You know,
we want to keep our ldl particle and
arrange that contributes to health and
doesn't increase our risk substantially
for
disease.
Yeah.
It's one of those things that it's,
it's so over simplified in the way
people describe them.
That sort of leads people to think,
well,
I just need to take a stat and almost
take a pill and this is the way it's
being described to people that have
these issues by doctors and these very
brief seven minute minute meetings that
they're having with their doctors for
the next person in line gets in this.
It's a really bad system.
It's a really bad system that and look
where we're having this conversation and
I'm a person who obviously I didn't go
to school for this and I'm trying to
take all this stuff in over a period of
years of reading and watching
documentaries and talking to people like
you and dr rhonda patrick and and you
know,
so many different people.
Rob wolf and so many dIfferent people
that are experts in nutrition and the
way the body processes nutrients and I'm
still baffled by a massive amount of it.
Given the many,
many,
many hours I've been paying attention to
it.
You know,
it's incredibly complex.
So complex.
I mean it's liKe any other pursuit.
I think the more you know,
the last,
you know,
the more you can just say,
you realize that you can spend your
lifetime,
you know,
learning about this and you still have
many lifetimes to go before you felt
like you really could master it.
Yeah.
I think dennis mckenna had a great way
of describing.
I'm learning something and realizing how
little you learn.
That one,
the bonfire of understanding increases.
IT illuminates the surface layer of
ignorance greater.
Yeah.
I love that.
Yeah,
that's exactly how I feel about this.
At the same time,
I think our knowledge is advancing and
we are in a different place even just 10
years ago than we were 10 years ago.
Yes.
We understand things.
So
I think maybe some doctors know,
right?
Like there's a lot of people that would
talk to their doctor and dr.
Golf,
oh,
that's nonsense.
Oh,
well these guys and these so called
experts and they'll go on about it.
Here's the interesting thing about that.
Number one is that,
uh,
there's a real lag time between what's
in the scientific literature that anyone
can access.
Now you know,
I mean they may not,
you may average person doesn't have
access to the full text,
but anyone could go to pubmed.gov
and pull up abstracts from the hundreds
of thousands of scientific studies that
are published and you will see if you do
that.
I mean if you're inclined to do that,
that they're,
you know,
the,
the vast majority of recent research
suggests that saturated dietary,
saturated fat and dietary cholesterol
are not major risk factors for heart
disease.
But the time it will take for that
knowledge to percolate down to the
average primary care provider is not
weeks or months or even years.
It's probably decades because that's how
long it took for the idea that saturated
fat and dietary cholesterol are bad for
us to get hammered into our heads.
I mean,
that started in the fifties and it
didn't really sink in,
I don't think until the eighties or the
nineties,
you know,
with the boneless chicken,
skinless chicken breast and the bagels
with no butter or cream cheese and the,
you know,
like that was my generation like that,
pasta,
carb loading and that whole thing.
That was 30 years aFter this whole
campaign started.
and unfortunately I think it's going to
take another couple of decades and
hopefully it will go faster this time.
And in there are some signs that it is
going faster.
But the average primary care provider,
they're seeing patients 30,
40 hours a week.
They have families,
they have other,
you know,
that theIr own health to consider.
They're not going home at night and
reading the scientific literature.
They are trying to take care of their
patients,
trying to live their own life and they
only know what they were taught in
medical school,
which,
you know,
unless they're doing continuing
education and the medical school tech
textbooks are out of date as soon as
they're printed.
Uh,
and they're based on studies that were
done 50 or 40 or 50 years ago.
So this is a huge problem in medical
education is that the current research,
you know,
the,
the public policy and the standard of
care is not based on the most recent
research and,
and the peer reviewed evidence that we
available to us now.
It's based off and on research that's
decades old.
This stuff takes so long.
The process people have these podcasts
and they go over him three or four times
and start taking notes and just try to
make these changes in their life.
If you wanted to give someone advice as
to what is the best way to proceed.
If someone's listening to this podcast
and they say,
okay,
obviously I really need to know what's
going on in my gut.
I need to know what'S going on with,
uh,
my,
my overall blood lipids,
my health.
Well yeah,
my nutrient density.
But what,
what,
what do,
what does the average person to do?
Yeah.
So I think the first very first thing is
I can set them up in three words,
eat real food.
And you know,
you can talk about paleo,
primal,
paleo template.
Okay,
that's bad.
You know,
I would argue that that's a step above,
but just eating real food,
like avoiding things that come in a bag
or a box,
you know,
butter comes into box.
All right,
let's not get too hung up on that.
But you know what I mean?
When can say that,
right?
Actual actual real food,
vegetables that come out come out of the
ground and fruits and nuts and seeds and
some,
even some tubers,
sweet potatoes,
I think white potatoes get a bad rap and
they're fine for most people as long as
they're not,
you know,
fried and crappy oil and the skins are
actually really good for you.
Good for you.
And you know,
eat some,
some good pasture raised organic if
possible,
animal products and wild caught fish.
Um,
if yOu can do that,
and I really think that,
that,
that would solve 80 percent of people's
problems if you're already doing that or
you've already got that down and you're
still having additional issues.
ThIs is where functional medicine comes
in,
which we've kind of touched on at
various points along the way.
Um,
but this is an,
is a relatively new and fast growing
branch of medicine that is focused on
addressing the underlying cause of
illness,
you Know,
taking the pebble out of the shoe
instead of just suppressing symptoms.
And there are several training
organizations out there.
Institute for functional medicine is
the,
is been around the longest and it's
pretty well known.
I have kresser institute which just
started,
we're trAining the 200.
We have 200 doctors and other healthcare
professionalS in the program now.
And you can go to these websites and
look for practitioners that practice
functional medicine and unfortunately
it's not yet at the level where there's
one on every corner,
like even like a yoga studio.
Um,
but it's changing fast.
And you know,
for example,
mark hyman,
who's a nine time number one New York
times bestselling author dot a health
expert.
He recently was tapped to start the
center for functional medicine at the
cleveland clinic,
which is a very prestigious medical
institution and they already have a six
month wait list and it's just,
it's blowing up.
So I think the tide is turning and,
and pretty soon a lot of people will be
seeing functional medicine
practitioners,
um,
but these are the practitioners that are
likely to be knowledgeable about how to
properly test your,
got,
how to assess your hpa access,
your stress tolerance and,
and,
um,
resilience.
How to look at your functional,
your blood chemistry panel.
So look at your blood sugar,
your lipids,
your metabolic function,
your vitamin d or b,
12 levels.
take all of that information and then
create a customized individual plan for
you based on all of your lab test
results,
your current symptoms and signs,
your health history,
your family history,
and your lifestyle and put all that
together and then make a plan for you.
And as you can imagine,
that takes time.
You know,
the,
the typical first appointment is more
like an hour and a half,
then seven minutes.
And it's also,
uh,
can be more expensive because there's a
lot of lab work that's done up front to
try to figure out what's causing the
problems.
But I would argue that it's less
expensive over the longterm because when
you address the root of the problem,
the,
the treatment is going to be way more
effective and it's going to be way
longer lasting.
And I think I can say from my own
personal experience from someone who's
changed their diet in eliminated almost
all sugar in terms of like added sugar,
very,
very little.
Do I take in a daily basis are
eliminated.
Almost all simple carbs and my energy
levels are so much better.
Um,
I don't craSh like I used to.
I feel like overall my health is better.
I talked about my,
um,
increased over the last few years of
probiotics,
made a giant benefit,
made.
It made a huge impact in terms of my
ability to recover from illnesses,
my ability to avoid on the sis.
And I have little kids so my kids are in
travel,
which I travel in airplanes and just
like disease vector labs,
you know.
But I survived them so much better than
a lot of my peers who don't take care of
themselves the same way.
It just,
it makes a big difference in that
overall quality of life difference is so
significant and it has such an impact on
your productivity and your energy
levels,
your happiness because you're not
constantly fighting diseases and
illnesses.
And that is another thing that people I
think ignore or maybe you are not really
aware of is the function of your health
and your immune system and your gut
biome and how it translates into your
actual personality.
That's a huge point.
I'm really glad you brought that up.
Um,
and it does that in a Couple of
different ways.
One Is just the actual chemical
influence that we talked about,
the year gut bacteria,
how it influences your brain.
Brain chemistry can affect your mood,
but the other I think is more,
uh,
related to just how you experienced your
life.
When you feel good versus when you feel
crappy.
like you pointed out,
your productivity increases,
you're just happier,
you have more time to be effective,
and you're probably able to be more
present with your kids and your,
your,
if you're in a relationship with your
partner.
And I mean it's,
it's a dramatic difference.
I think one of the downsides of how
adaptable we are as human beings is we
can get used to some pretty heavy stuff
and people who,
a lot of people I think are sick and
they're not,
or at least they're not.
Well,
you know,
they're not really healthy and there's a
kind of normalization of that.
The top that happens in our culture,
um,
you know,
it's just common to that people are
taking drugs,
people are taking more than one drug.
Uh,
they're,
they're just,
they don't feel well,
they're not sleeping well.
Um,
you know,
that's common,
but I don't think it's normal and
there's a really important difference
between what's common and what's normal.
I think that's an awesome point and I
think
this has been a great conversation.
I really,
really thank you for coming in here and
thanks for your awesome website.
There's so much data and so much
information there.
A chris kresser.com
for people that are interested,
there's a ton of articles up there and
if if they want to follow any of your
other work were.
Can you direct them?
Yeah.
Chris kresser.com
is the main place I have a podcast
called revolution health radio and
itunes and then for any clinicians that
are interested in learning more about
this approach is kresser institute.com.
Thank you chris.
Appreciate it,
man.
This was awesome.
I'm going to do this again.
Love to take it in folks.
Uh,
we will be back tomorrow.
Who's here tomorrow?
Tony hinchcliffe the golden pony.
Unhealthy cigarette smoking little fuck
he'll be here tomorrow.
See ya.
Bye.
I love you guys.
That was great.